all right and we are live the last word
with Lorca Dido and ebon tiss looks like
most special guests going on even what's
going on today
well besides the fact that destiny of
course exploded again this week we have
an awesome guest joining us so see if
you can make a blush here we go loadout
so let's get to event welcome to the
last word episode number 93 let us know
the glorious Friday we're back in front
of that campfire for some more looters
shooter discussion I'm extremely excited
about our special guests so we gonna get
right into it I want to introduce a Lord
whom the ILP recently got a chance to
cross paths with at PAX East 2020 now it
is more one of the most passionate and
hardcore destiny players in the
community but he has the crown of sorrow
and incoming God in the salvation ray
jackets to prove it introducing the host
of the bobbies on YouTube twitch channel
and one half of gaming's power couple
with Lady Lauren side the Lord of all
things destiny in Pokemon and the
survivor of the spiciest ramen challenge
the tower has ever seen laughs of the
tri-state and making his debut into the
realm of the last word mom made Lord
Bobby's on how you doing sir oh I'm
doing great that was the greatest intro
I've ever had I feel I'm just gonna keep
playing that every time I like this man
yeah you like switches that's what can
you clip that please I'm feeling good
I'm excited I am as hype as I'm sure you
guys are and everyone else out there
it's a good time to be a destiny fan for
sure there's a little bit absolute
pleasure to what they have you in robot
I can't find what this is man you find
out that you were a desti PHA well I'll
see what week we had our interview and I
think the bond kind of started there ee
ah this guys are no bad yeah Lauren sent
me the night before she's again there's
this podcast and they talk about destiny
wait destiny des yeah I'm like I looked
you guys what I've heard of this before
me I'd be honest I know my stuff I'll
talk a little destiny it I was
loke you were elated mission and I was
told they were like yeah you know you
don't kill husband come on I'm
absolutely you know come on then we
started bobbing and I'm like it was
funny it was during the joy it was like
a mini he was like a mini destiny
podcast broke out you're like sorry
we're talking about dusty but we're
still talking about it so we got to get
this one more piece and I was like she's
over there just like are we done no I
know where he was like yo you know what
a new Conte come out you know boy got
take off work I said I mean cuz I've
been here before I know I know that
looks like I need that other editor can
you call them in oh yeah well I checked
already for for this next week I'm like
your editors are around right they're
not gonna be on vacation they're gonna
be alright cause I'll be busy you sweet
I'll maybe do a video but that boy's
gonna be worthy got that grind to go but
glad to have you bad but I mean man
what's going on with you bad oh just
been the stockpile in a few bounties and
trying to get ready for this crazy week
breaking down trailers screenshot at a
time
it's been an awesome week so just kind
of like cruising along Oh trailer drops
oh there's a website up oh this that and
the other and I'm like and in the 21
before the season drops those like just
waiting to see how long that was gonna
be it's a book so we've got a lot going
on yeah I played the neo2 little like
beta over the weekend the last-chance
trial that boss whooped my butt and I
finally there was like maybe an hour and
a half left in the trial cuz it was like
Friday through Sunday and I'm literally
I like 12:30 in the morning it goes like
til 2:00 for me because it was like 12
o'clock Pacific I beat the boss at 12:30
in the morning yo cutting clothes dude
I've been playing through neo one that
game is so much longer than I thought
it's crazy yeah like how much content
isn't that one but then this one has
some tweaks to and then dude this guy
just whooped my butt and I was like what
no so yeah that was a nice little break
to get away and then I came back booted
up and was like I
I finished that one it was like and
let's see if I can start stockpiling a
couple bounties been streaming late at
night mmm yes that's stuck you see so me
Osiris I was literally just knocking out
weekly and daily bounties I'm on my
third character my hunter I haven't
touched and so long I pretty much
haven't played since drifter my I
literally would like login picked up the
season pass last season and then you get
like three sets and I throw a couple
tokens at checks and I was like cool and
max level next that's all I did for my
hunter so I know what to go on this one
I haven't even played shadow keep to go
get like the moon bounties done on my
hunter so I've been living on the Titan
a lot so I saw Titans got some crap this
week we're gonna talk about that later
not not feeling the love thanks Bungie
love you but the Titans are uh we don't
eat that many crayons oh that was not
justified oh yeah we go get to it we get
to it talk about me some stuff went down
yeah so first thing that happened I
frickin Bungie and these trailers man
little hype like I've watched that thing
more times than I should it's like a two
minute trailer and I'm probably spent 30
minutes of my life watching that thing
oh yeah whatever when they I woke up
when we unlocked trials and they
unleashed the behind-the-scenes the
second one oh my god it's here and I
just watch it over and over it's finally
happening the feels to feel yeah I was
that was for me I hate all right baby I
was I was at debut did while you were
those while you were sleeping I know we
caught the cheetah he hooked me up I got
the call I got the message
so I was alright it went down yeah yeah
baby it was so great I was so hyped that
I was like even if I'm at PAX tour that
one day which was either Wednesday night
or Thursday night whatever it was
I'll do even if I have a terrible setup
which I did sorry off I had the terrible
side with a terrible back we're back on
good audio last week we back on good
audio now we met but of yeah we had to
talk about it bad because again that
diet trailer really hit the fields for
me you know and in the PvP community
that love that mode so that was a good
start
yeah still I mean that was like kind of
the kickoff to all of what's been per
spot like transpiring in the past week
and a half basically so that was crazy
packs happened everybody seems to have
survived mostly not too many sniffles or
anything and then it was like Tuesday
okay like director's cut was crazy we
got that piece and yes and then now
we've got trailer website completely
loaded and at wha the mall breakdown for
you guys so we want to start with the
trailer just for you guys wouldn't you
watch that what were the pieces that
stuck out to you big moments anything
you guys were liking a little sneak
peeks you liked uh I mean I've got
screenshots I can literally just browse
through so what do you guys what were
you guys thoughts on stuff what's good
Bobby man probably was about what
happened you saw that trailer so I saw a
trailer and I was I was it has that like
dark ominous tone which I love in any
game or any movie when it's like evil is
coming here we go like bunker down it's
about to get crazy and one thing I
noticed after watching it was a bunch
was an uprising a lot of like knives and
daggers Mike a little more uh melee
weapons or something that's bobby
question is it me someone told me that I
don't know if it's true
did they change the voice actress
somebody said that's not the same voice
actress but I'm in water or not mm-hmm
did sound a little different yeah yeah
but you continued Sarris what did ya
think about it I remember yeah my in my
there might be different off to go back
and listen to it dark ominous and just I
love when it's it's just there like
unloading all this new stuff coming then
of course you know there's that one
Guardian in the the tower there with
that mask everyone thinks is oldrin so
when I first saw it I'm never looking
like oh that's a cool looking mask and
then I started seeing on Twitter I'm
like it's old root soldier it's gotta be
him so yeah I mean war mine it's just so
much so much stuff coming
well you know like the new the bunkers
the night falls the new harder night
falls it's I'm excited man it's just
Phil just packed full of goodies it was
like what two minutes not even two
minutes yeah boom here's everything oh
yeah yes absolutely
Bobby was feeling it yeah and I like
seeing what's called the fourth Horseman
is that the shotguns of all yeah yes
yeah as a non g1 player I am all for
bringing bringing back the the old guns
for me to try so excited for that sure
it's nice nice that's what's up II was
feeling Oh feeling was lit I couldn't
stop watching it literally like I've
found the background music to that now I
know what that song is and this the band
that does that just like whatever album
that is that they have there's another
song on there I'm like there's like
three or four songs you could just like
put crazy awesome trip they're all like
epic music it's so that alone is awesome
it's like brain I've always been into
music yeah they have oh forget that
what trailer was I think I might've been
for shadow keep there was this really
good song I know dmg tweeted about he
was a fan of the band yeah they're on
point there yeah miss ray Elizabeth
so I mean you saw everything from we got
teases of exotics we got more mind
obviously talking at you we've got a
MechWarrior in there we've got a new
public hmm
shout out by the way to your better half
sir and I will say better just because I
would do the same thing for my life
Lawrence Hyde is hosting us right now
thank you very much for the whole Lady
of the round though yeah if you guys
want to go get a good laugh on for the
day go check out her content you will
laugh pretty hard mm-hmm but yeah I mean
it starts out with like this just kind
of the epic story of like a cabal crazy
you know Sion who got away wants to go
smash the last city with the Almighty I
was like oh damn like that's that's how
the trailer starts so we're getting
larger and larger kind of like issues
that we've got to go deal with and it
seems like that saiyanz kind of done his
thing and anna-marie beat him up but the
controls are on fire and the show
headed towards pretty much the last city
on earth and I'm going uh that's a big
ship in that cities not that big so yeah
we in trouble yeah and then it's like
okay are we gonna arm the war mind and
then it's kind of breaking down like how
they phrase like okay guardians have to
make the tough decisions and I'm like is
this Paulo is this of all I having to
like swallow his pride and work with the
war mind or is it that we've got to be
like hey this isn't gonna be like a
democratic vote of humanity and be like
we're just gonna kick off the war mine
and hope he saves our butt but if he's
on he's also now on that bad then we
obviously have the Tees of trials
exotics pool finishers and just I mean
it's an epic trailer no question about
it so I mean we can go through the piece
by piece I know I teased like 20
different discussion topics right there
but you good you good I jump in um yeah
but was it was a pleasant surprise but
you all know what's coming you know I
think one of the best things about the
Annual Pass structure is that that final
week when the previous seasons about the
end is that anticipation I wonder what's
the next threat what's gonna happen and
you know this one you know we definitely
anticipate obviously with the Osiris and
Rasputin cinematic we knew something was
coming in that regard
but what was cool was just I didn't
think we'd see Zavala anytime soon as
far as being a main character in the
next conflict so it's actually cool to
see him as much as he's not loved since
you know he did envoy Creed he ain't
right for caged like right now in these
destiny streets but um you know it's
good to see him you know it's good to
see the whole and a great thing you know
shoutout to after cross it I don't know
if it's true but there's there's some
type of relationship daughter so you
know we gonna we gonna figure our
father-daughter thing
but I have to reach out to by for that
part but as far as the whole set up it
look cool I like the whole powering up
to war mine all these different
locations we gotta go get that going on
obviously the trials inclusion was dope
you know a lot of stuff a lot of
information there so it looked good shot
of the press guy he's an Arab a
there's a lot of people they got a soft
spot for Ana so yeah a lot of people bad
but now it looked good I like the the
exotics and stuff like that that way
that were teased oh I'm ready man I'm
ready and I'm glad that because it lets
me wear a lot of the worry was that we
knew trials were coming but the PvE guys
are gonna be like well what I'm gonna do
I'm not gonna play trials all day so it
was so good to see hey if you're not a
pvp person we got stuff for you so that
that part was cool yeah so we can
honestly just start breaking it down
kind of go piece by piece and of
everything first thing story obviously I
kind of teased that a little bit mmm a
scion from the sundial kind of escaped
somehow got aboard the almighty
basically turned it aimed it at earth
blast City and then busted the controls
so basically just kind of steered it at
it and said alright going and then the
general other side of that is we've got
you know the tough decision of do we
activate the war mind which is
potentially we know it's kind of capable
of keeping the traveler in the solar
system so if it's able to do that
obviously might be able to handle a ship
but then what do you guys how do you
guys feel this is all gonna go down I
know we have the tease of like oldrin
and worthy just kind of want to get into
the story bits of everything that's been
teased in this trailer and the website
and stuff like that mm-hmm
let's get it yeah it's um I feel like
the world of destinies in the chaotic at
least as far as the lore and like
currently what's going on in the story
of what they're trying to show with
Osiris going to the war mine and then
kind of feeling like that's an argument
that's about to happen there's a lot of
turmoil I think I really you know this
past season or with a shadow keep but
you know I've seen the darkness now so I
feel like a lot of darkness is creeping
in a lot of stuff is about to change a
lot of bad things are gonna happen you
know we got a ship that's plummeting
toward last city so I as my the evil
side of me wants some stuff to go down
and want something you know something
bad to throw it through a wrench into
the plan of of destiny so I'm excited I
think there's a lot of turmoil a lot of
chaos that's about to happen you turn
down for yeah it was cool like I think
for me was like I like the idea of um
you'd offer I've got all about the all
let's keep round yeah and even thinking
about the almighty so I'm just like oh
yeah it's still there like yeah there's
no Gaul and all that but you know
whatever so you got that aspect and are
we gonna I'm out to ahead to talk about
the possible ocean thing we just focus
on we're just going any lower story
stuff so yeah throw it in why not
the older thing is very interesting
I am not sure cuz part of me says when
you look at it it look for look at the
shot it's very weird like the place of
it like why there's the folk you got
ikora that is it focus on initially I'm
like okay that's us right as a guardian
maybe right yeah then it's just the way
it shot it's very focused and again if
you've been paying attention to the to
the lore you know that mmm misty I don't
know if I'm pronouncing it right but the
law card that was found basically says
that Aldrin is running around you know
outside the outskirts of the city
and people don't he doesn't know who he
is doesn't have any recollection and
people are just angry with him so as a
result he wears his mask all the time so
it kind of makes sense and we will be
like let's be real like we've been
wanting to know winter good they're
gonna address that story beat the one of
the greatest things are forsaken is
where that you know you know what you
call it a flyby is that ghosts and
brings and brings him back and we like
y'all Oh dudes baddies you know Easy's
we've been chosen you know he's one of
us and let's be real hunter still need a
van guy so this is interesting
um I hope it is like I said I hope it is
Aldrin cuz I want that story in advance
I want the classic epic scene when I
Cora finds out who the hell that is
cuz she gonna be pissed today I can't
read I cannot wait like the what I'm
trying to think if the motion capture
and like the like when they're recording
that thing the amount of lake intensity
in that room when you just like it's
gonna be like palpable tension to when
that's all stuff goes down so know if
they can actually pull that off I would
love to see that yeah I would love it to
be like what what a story beat that
would be like yes go a bit and I know I
saw someone outside of if you look like
where he is in the tower that's supposed
to be where he was bound or in some
other lore so
why would they you know what's like why
would they put it there if everything is
done intentionally so intentionally
yeah I'm started because that first at
first Bobby I was saying no only because
they felt the helmet felt kind of
warlock II yeah I was like well maybe
that's just us and then it up but then
as I keep thinking about I think it's
definitely possible I would love to see
it I mean mmm again I saw a Paul tastic
write an article is like you know we're
kind of at this point of hey what's
gonna happen at the pyramid ships please
let something happen in year 16 like
yeah that's been building up for like
five years like and then we had older
and we did the Dreaming City and then we
saw him wake up and we're like dude he's
just chilling out there i watch so yeah
we happen so you I mean it is like and
they do very intentional stuff I mean
loose miss word choice of like
italicizing one word or all of this
other little stuff sometimes typically
means something so if you're looking at
what looks to be again civilians in a
city setting and there's one person with
looking up and they have a helmet on
your leg mmm you know is just the
Guardian or is it this dude and it's a
helmet none of us have ever seen ever so
it's very unique so I could definitely
see it if it does happen
very cool T's like people definitely
reading in would be nice yeah though I'd
love to see it I just don't know if
they're ready for that story but God
knows that needs to get here so I'd be
totally done well let's do it let's do
this laughs well last theory we can say
that since um what does shadow keep
considered here three I don't know of
just well you had done your one mm-hmm
then picking it up Forsaken forsaking -
so this is Decimus in year three yep
this is year 300 K which is Chelsea yeah
so as a result like you could kind of
say that they're mimicking because we
could kind of say like on a season of
the dawn kind of mimics the curse of
Osiris cadence we can kind of say you
know season of the word worthy now
mimics the warm on right all right it
what comes now so in theory the Forsaken
cadence and dreaming city is up next
because it seems like let's be real
these are seems like kind of reprisals a
little bit you know I'm saying as far as
the story beats sort of
is everything like this this is
technically in my mind war mine 2.0
about you know so it would be cool to
set it up and your boy take the bass
conf at the end it up I love listen I
don't like the other day Osiris cutscene
this is the older people will lose it
what they gotta like again I know the
hardcore pissed off right now I was that
left for us to do but one thing I like
as a hardcore destiny playing hunk or d1
is seeing these story beats actually
come together and go somewhere so if
they were able to do that from a
continuity standpoint that would be fine
like yeah I think it was like take it
one step further remember it's like
season 10 is building season 11 you
don't want to miss going into whatever
the expansion is so you had curse of
Osiris this is gonna be war mine then
you have potentially older and come back
you somehow resolve the dreaming city
like forever cycle and then that is
either maybe savathun or the pyramid
ships that come in in the expansion like
one leading to another like the timing
seems like it would fit it does so I
would mmm that'd be we're gonna see man
some patience being able to like hold
all this stuff in because I feel like
there's always been so much story and so
much lore that they can just like yours
everything but instead they hold on to
it little little piece out you know that
eat it oh they drinking it and it's just
all you just just want it all you sit
there and you're like oh there's all
this story and so much of it that I had
learned about so I didn't play d1 and
then I start seeing it peeking in the
detune like yeah like let's go let's go
zone so fix everything like I haven't I
have no idea about this though so I am
you miss the glory that is getting King
mmm oh you poor child
I've watched many many old videos of
people doing reeds and stuff so I've
seen never got to play myself but I've
lived there other people so no that's
good interesting to hear your
perspective yes I like you know you you
want to be doing something in the game
that it's not just random it's like not
just some random one-off thing like all
this story from here this is coming from
this place and mmm
yeah keep doing it keep building it up
on G in the darkness that when they when
you when you go to that pyramid ship and
you see your projection of yourself in
that voice that was one of those moments
destiny where I was just sitting there
like okay it's going it's getting crazy
what's about to happen I had a story
beat at the end of a raid and these are
things I've been asking you know emails
we went to a garden of gcx you know I
literally be lined right over to the
raid team well Sunday I've got her name
like everybody's talking to DJ everybody
I'm like listen a porch I said listen
yeah I got the best rate ever in gaming
in mopping right I was like the only
thing you gotta do is you gotta do that
story continuity what like how thinking
but the story leads into the raid and
then when you beat the Raider you gets
up and that was what forsaken did
fantastic yeah so I was like you can't
have these little one-off raised like
scourging a pass and and crime star not
saying that the Rays are trash it's just
that you have to build it up like why
are we doing this why are we going in
there why is this threat even an issue
and that is the key so yeah bad like I'm
loving this I'm loving how guard to
salvation by the way we get our jackets
what we getting our jackets y'all what's
going on with that yeah I got a lot of
stuff that says partially filled in my
my water history on destiny but I don't
even get my Megatron shirt will divorce
that we'd be I'm waiting I want my dear
Miss Carolina they dragged us through
we've jumped at the backpack got that uh
got that done right yep yes I mean but
if you even you guys are like you can
take everything with season of the
worthy it's like yeah you like that
title fits in three different places is
older and worthy of somebody sitting
there saying yeah are we worthy to
respeet and for all these challenges
it's gonna put us through and then in
flawless trials are you worthy of doing
that like there's multiple levels that
title works just for the season so I
don't know it's got potential to be kind
of epic and yeah it feels like we have
to prove ourselves as Guardians in many
many ways and I want there to be some
sort of like
judge me at the end of life all you know
X amount of Guardians who the trials do
this and that you are worthy maybe it's
maybe it's suspect I'll or maybe I don't
know some sort of way to like give back
to the to the hardcore players the
worthy ones mean everyone ideally should
be able to become worthy but there
should be some sort of like top tier
worthy us you are the top Guardian so
it'll be interesting to see what they do
with that yeah I think yeah I want to a
it makes sense that I'd even you nailed
it like mm-hmm
sees another word his story beat it has
to be worthiness why is he he's worthy
of the light he's been chosen by the
ghost to Travellers chosen Oh drew it
makes so you always gotta be here I'm in
now I mean I realize it all in I'm all
in there yeah I'm going with that that's
that's that that's all just there's no
doubt and then the other side of the
worthy is rest butan so we see em Savola
overt like peek over the trailer saying
hey we've got to make the tough
decisions talks about us running in the
bunkers and then we see this like
we can say is like Rasputin's mech like
the Mars yeah
like big giant mech and then he hunkers
down and gone to all fours and fires
what looks to be the javelin out of his
head yeah I saw that after watching it a
bunch of times like that's weird is this
is like a you know because we're gonna
have legendary lost sectors we're gonna
have bunkers we'll talk about the stuff
do you guys think this is like a bunker
boss is this like a cinematic working in
our favor is this like Rasputin's like
in you know mobile form I mean where do
you guys think this whole Rasputin's is
gonna come in do you feel we're gonna be
like is rasputin's asked us to be like
hey you gotta clear the stuff out for me
or hey I've set up challenges I gotta
see if you're actually worth my time do
you which way you guys yeah this is
worthy for worthy of using the weapon
yeah I think I think that neck thing is
on our side I'd read somewhere and I
think it was some old lore that they had
spoken about none of these mechs in a
way and so I think that they are on our
side maybe it's something you have to
activate and the bunkers and they fight
with us maybe it helps beat the boss but
that's cool I love when they bring in a
new element like this like okay now
there's a next we fight this is whether
so mmm-hmm yeah I'll jump in um I agree
I agree I think that um yeah we
definitely have to prove our that is too
recipe and we obviously there's these
bunkers that's hidden that we have to go
around and unlock and everything seems
to be preparing for a defense like
defending him arming him so that he can
do what he needs to do to protect you
Betty
obviously the Omani is this threat so um
yeah and like Bobby said like I'm always
excited when I see a new enemy type
character type whatever like you know
one of the complaints about a destino
it's you're fighting the same three
things over like do we getting new stuff
so I like that aspect and to be honest
like I'm gonna be real like this trailer
surprised me more the amount of stuff I
didn't let me wear like that the Caesar
door was light a little bit you know it
was a lot of story stuff some like that
but as far as contest I was actually
surprised I don't like this looks like a
decent amount of content I know we're
not getting started getting a read per
se you know saying but it still seems
like a lot of stuff to do
that's what I'm rolling with would you
would you I would heat uh I just don't
want to see what the hell this guy is
cuz like I mean I went through I have
I'm literally looking at one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven of a dozen screenshots of this
one guy and he's in the video for
probably like twelve frames so it's like
every frame cuz yes he's got he's got
like full-on shoulder large shoulder
four limbs standing on legs then kind of
drops down and he's bigger shoulder pads
than any Titan you've ever seen but when
like the head fires a javelin I'm like I
want to know for one the scale of how
big he is
I can't tell us it's like Guardian size
are we looking at like holy crap you're
big or are you like a dog I can't tell
scale and then to just of course like
you know the more rest butan talks the
better so I'd love to hear more just
rescue Tintin maybe you got a subtitle
it so I'll actually see what the hell he
says for once but no like crazy Russian
robots yeah
but ya know I was like I'm very
intrigued to see and then as you said
we've got the bunkers legendary lost
sectors I think it's got I mean you can
break stuff down and be like yeah it's
probably not gonna be you know the most
packed of like everything thrown into
one but I definitely think as they keep
building on these seasons and how
they're kind of pulled in the lore along
I like where it's going and so far for
ten bucks I always like it's easy to say
and I think many people have ten bucks
we get our money's worth hands-down not
a question we get our 10 bucks easy
every time I was bro that's right mmm no
doubt no doubt yeah so then through the
trailer we go through of course we've
got a tease of some gear that we're
gonna get naming li3 exotics now one we
very gut laid out for us and that is
Tommy's matchbox we've got the Tommy gun
Auto rifle we've also got the what looks
to be cabal slug looks to be a like a
giant minigun but if you'd like somebody
mold like a colossus image you guys can
see it almost nearly matches the barrel
and then we've got of course fourth
horseman stow on the exotic on the
weapons front but once you guys have
seen anything and also you got the
trials weapons and things like that any
weapons you guys have seen you're
intrigued about curious how it's gonna
work thoughts
I'm excited for Tommy's matchbook I have
never been much of an auto when I first
started playing I was like Uriel's gift
was rinse it off best go ahead haven't
used an auto since then so I always like
having I like just holding the mouse
clicker down instead of having to click
every time so it's nice so you know a
little lazy just mow down enemies
it looks dope it sounds though and you
know it might be like a new little
archetype of Auto rifle so that L
exciting always excited for a new
shotgun I just watched something someone
post on Twitter how the melting power of
it so oh it's it's like five five slugs
as fast as you can and then yeah the
other one that looks like the the
cabal's guys like machine gun things so
yeah I like them all I think they're all
good choices I don't you know we don't
need any more hand cannons
I'm not a sidearm fan so elbows ruin was
a cool little sidearm to get but it just
felt like a 1/16 version of 1k voices or
something so yeah a little bit yeah
yeah just like what I what I do like
though not to go to off-topic is the D
what do they call it here the upper tier
power the war mine and jolly they're
like little get the artifact yeah I
can't think of the word that I would
like I like that I hope they they sell a
replica of that because mm-hmm yeah that
looks like a chain on it yeah it reminds
me a little bit of like the old the
weapons from the movie Troy like the
kind of you know sharper edges and
whatnot than that but it's still like I
like seeing that movie it's like Brad
looking was the first movie I saw three
times in the theater yeah yeah big big
sword guys and fighting so yeah but new
exotics look dope I'm excited for them
hopefully you know I always like when
they bring in hopefully new guns that
change archetypes not just another gun
so mmm yeah I'm excited they all look
very fun to use no doubt no doubt
yeah man same thing like Tommy's
matchbook look cool um this awesome hand
cannon it looked interesting um we get
into that all - Russian - all we gotta
do right so yeah like razor for husband
for spin you know is a classic you don't
you're funny I've never really used that
uh no I don't use it much I probably
used it on like some specialist arc
singe you know load-out and way if you
just like you want to melt something you
would absolutely destroy stuff but it's
range is that a stat of its like 5 range
it's up in front of them for it to be
used so is it like because it's like the
opposite of Acuras it hits as hot as a
curious but it's like mad cool I don't
remember you I remember getting that gun
late in d1 I mean it's basically a
insanely fast firing like you load all
five slugs in and all the barrels that's
just looking tu-tu-tu-tu-tu and you're
like take six years to reload so you got
a plan when to use that thing but if you
need to - you a butt ton of damage from
a shotgun into something up nose that's
what you mmm speaking of up close I hope
they changed battle mechanics cuz I know
they keep trying to get us away from
just sitting there and sniping and
destroying enemies the problem was with
bosses I mean they're stopping you yeah
yeah I really hope they tuned / delete
that SOT because I like getting up close
yeah cuz it attracts you it makes you do
the things that they don't like us doing
what you're staying distance if you
gotta stop and didn't blow us away from
the map you know I'm saying so it's like
I completely agree they've got to
introduce something else so that you
know we get into utilizing weapons like
this because a lot of us want to be
aggressive and you know up close yeah
and I don't want to just sit there in a
Rift and just unload all my shotgun but
if what I want is more movement based
bosses so
should you boss move out reload get back
together other guys you know mid-range
pecking out and then you can go in
boom get your shot in so I agree we'll
see we'll see what they do with that
yeah I was kind of wondered on the
bosses we were talking about that
basically cuz mm-hmm as playing through
like other games it was nice to get a
little perspective because we live in
this game too long and you're like I'm
kind of like shaded whatever but I was
even playing through neo and there's a
boss and I was just wondering because
they always want us to and it was all
about the whole sniper but like you know
sniper nerve 20% damage and you even
think about like sanctified mind he's
floating in the air when you have to do
damage to him how else yeah yeah and
then same thing you said like if you
think about nightfall Master nightfall
modifiers you've got mm-hm
you know the push back on I cannot
remember her name and the Scarlet keep
but it pushes you even farther is one of
the modifiers in the push back is even
farther well like of course I'm not
gonna go get close so then yes it's
gonna be Scouts or snipers or gradient
it's gonna be something gotta use that
range and now they're buffing autos and
bring about fourth horseman which you
have to be right next to them they're
buffing swords I mean all these things
like if you want me to use a sword
you've got to let me get next to them or
find a different way and as I was
playing one of the bosses it's a big
giant centipede but it's got a lot of
segments and if you actually get to a
point you kind of smash down all the
little segments kind of break apart mmm
why would I boss that is made up of
multiple things you do some certain
thing yeah one sniper shot like you hit
a crit it splits pins your use of an
auto rifle something needed I need to go
mowed down a whole bunch of pieces kind
of the way they you know they had some
similar mechanic in Leviathan final boss
that has multiple segments where you
can't just focus on one single point you
got to focus on like a hundred little
things and you can't use a sniper at
build a boss things we use other weapons
don't smash me to keep me a distance
though you know glass is asking you a
question he say as a played d1
is the fourth horseman pretty much a
stronger shotgun izanagi uh you don't
load it into one single shot but I mean
it is it's a very quick burst and a very
slow reload so I mean in a sense yeah
you get one quick shot and that's gonna
be a little bit of a minute but the
range is so short
mm-hmm it's
basically the exact opposite so it's
just if it's an art I think it was for
if I always wanted to say it was five
shots in the magazine not for cuz it's
got four barrels but there was always
five shots I think which was weird but
it was art shotgun high knee range lot
of damage best way to drive do you do
y'all fake is gonna be Bobby you think
it's gonna be heavy or is it gonna go in
a special that would be interesting
because since they changed shotguns to
not be oh they have the one-act
actresses heavy right now because of the
way it looks not like too big of a
shotgun I'm feeling special okay yeah I
probably say special it's always always
always tricky with exotics cuz yeah I
wish there is a way to have multiple
exotics or just some game mode you could
just deck yourself out and use all the
dope exotics but yeah it's uh at least a
mode right what if we go a little mode
like that laughs so I've been tweeting
at Bungie and just tweeting into the
universe that I want a PvP mode or
there's no super so basically reverse
mayhem words comes down to all weapon
mechanics I'm okay with abilities you
know that's fine we can keep abilities
and grenades that's fine but no supers I
think that would be really really cool
way to like and then maybe even that
like all right you want to use two
exotics you can't use a third weapon you
can use a heavy distracting I love
changes and stuff like that that really
you know just for fun kind of how I like
when they you know T stuff and try
different stuff out so that's something
I would yeah I wish they would give I
wouldn't even do random stuff like that
in crucible labs be like yeah hey we're
experiment with this really goofy mode
there's no supers you might you do have
a grenade no melee abilities to guns
haul exotics you can use like yes yeah
and I always wonder how hard that would
be because they have so many limitations
I'm silt into your inventory like one
exotic only like I don't know how hard
it is gonna break the system like I put
to it and the game just shuts down yeah
by what like like I think Call of Duty
used to do it's kind of like a an exotic
gun game or something like that way
maybe you start from one but you start
with a sign on everybody starts with
ours I mean whoever gets killed like
they go up up in level in different
archetypes or stuff like that
whether it be exotics legendary so just
some cool things to kind of
the meta you know yeah kind of stuff
yeah like momentum controller that was
awesome I thought that was a really cool
game mode I mean it was crazy but it's
you get your shot off first you're gonna
get the kill right away no matter you
know you're using Jade rabbit from
across Metin boop Chuck only what was
fun rabbit there it was crazy
I mean I even tried like bringing some
other stuff in I was playing the other
day because it was the weekly rotator
and elaborate thorns like in here boom
two shots a thorn dead and I was you
know just body shot with snipers so
stuff like that is cool so I hope they
take something like American Patrol and
build upon it and you might reverse
mayhem idea or just something new
something crazy and just you know just
for fun not competitive stuff I would
love an exotic gun game and just go
through and like me to just the line of
exotics you get it got a kill with each
one
I'd be hilarious like you start off
maybe what I do will you start off like
you know a couple primaries throw heavy
and occasionally you get like a grenade
launcher you know you're gonna gotta
kill it got to get a kill with Darcy or
something like that and like like stuff
like that was a setup that would be cool
I was I mean I don't know how much that
would again break the game and be
difficult but if sometimes the fix
loadout would be nice for them to do to
truly yeah just even just for a mode
just to level the playing field book
just for a game mode and you never know
what what comes from that and even
someone you tried different weapons they
don't normally try like oh crap
I like this boat I wanted to use or
people still use árboles right now facts
like let's be real we have to do beetle
Komodo quest like yeah I never really
use árboles no it's actually pretty good
when every gun is good once you've been
down that's what when people ask me
about destiny and they're like I'm gonna
play Destin what you do I'm like play
everything try everything
shoot everything cuz you're not no
everything's good everything's viable
you can go in an EVP with the worst
weapons if you're good at it you can
play it but every gun mod it's very very
viable obviously you know there's the
best ttk weapons and whatnot gonna be
sweat lord but that's that's person what
I love about the game is that everything
is viable talk about play how you want
to play talk about best gun game no
matter mmm
that's what I would he
[Laughter]
but yeah I was like so the trailer kind
of finishes up with exotics and then it
teases of worse into the other piece
of what what I want to know is it says
empower every Ally what does that mean
oh we like buffing ourselves in some PvE
activity that parties of this leg I'm
looking man of we got going on we're
going we like is Rasputin is alder and
like how far these like allies reaching
as you guys are saying that yes legit I
don't know
and they all say and they are holding
stuff back there probably see good I
love that they learn their lesson oh
they showed us everything and then spent
a whole week or whatever in the quarters
of time it's like oh it's a gun that we
knew her I can if I was one of those
guys spending you know uncountable
amount of hours sitting there looking at
Excel spreadsheets I would have been
like that's it I'm done
it's taking a break that's why I love
this kata swears like you know we're not
going to show you everything I'm saying
and this is good I'm excited I'm
definitely a definite part for this
season so far
mmm yeah so a couple other things we got
in the trailer of course a little bit of
a tease for trials that we've talked
about a little bit last week but as we
didn't have you on battles our bots on
trials I know you haven't played d once
we've literally never played it before
yeah how much do you like or sue it like
thoughts very much so I never when
charles the nine was out in d2 I never
played Excel wasn't really good at PvP
mmm-hmm now I'm good above average I can
snipe I can I've done it all especially
I think what I got me a lot better at
pvp was playing a lot of iron banner and
doing weapons specific bounties to just
learn about different weapons play
little classes and just get my shot down
get everything down I'm pumped I was
playing a limited elimination last night
with my trials team and it nice I love
the game of it I love you get that first
shot you get that three-on-two advantage
and you just go and you can end it so I
like the game mode I think it's uh it's
very it's it's fun it's you know you you
play your best on that first 30 seconds
if you do good boom you win the round if
not all right start another one so we
were we were we were down like 1 2 3
games last night we just need focus up
and boom and just won them all and won
the game like all right like nice I'm
down for this I really like it I really
like that elimination style I know I was
talking to clintus last night who was
home playing with and he was saying that
in one season in one season they had
bounties that you could get by not
having to go win seven in a row so as
long as their stuff for me to be able to
do and not have to win that's good I
know I don't want it to be super easy
but there's definitely you know keep I
was watching someone talking they said
you need the casuals me the people in
there that aren't the best and aren't
the great pvp view players so that you
know you can get to that seven in a row
bring people in so that when you go in
it's not overwhelming obviously you know
there's the talk with the artifact power
and week one not you know unfortunately
it's not gonna be disabled mm-hmm we'll
see how that goes but I have high hopes
I'm excited I am ready to go yeah man
literally what you said I mean for me it
was the same same thing which is kind of
like you know but for me that's my rate
no I'm PvE guy too
but you know PvP shout to citizen
shout-out to addict you know we would
Friday's would come and it was basically
definitely became a new game on Friday
that weekend trials when that came he
was er came and you went to that you
went to the reef back in d1 to go you
know see brother Vance whatever and do
the thing and you nailed it because
literally what I said last time you know
when I was at PAX doing this remotely we
eat is they have to have that balance
right the hardcore is going to play this
mode try to go for the total lighthouse
I get it but the casuals you can't
discourage them you have to give them
something and be honest like I listen
I'm above average you know I'm saying so
my whole thing was I wasn't going to the
lighthouse a lot I'll be I already went
twice I wasn't really going to that I'll
often so what would happen is I would
get those trials bounties right whether
it be just getting a certain amount of
kills a certain amount of rounds in so
that I'm in there and then that would
allow me to then get a chance and it
wasn't an adept weapon
it wasn't an adept version of the weapon
it wasn't the one that you get it was
you know III got a doctrine of passing
my first one like that was like man I
got like a really good Trials gun I can
compete I would get like maybe an armor
set one piece of an armor set so it's
like you you would build it up slower
yeah but it incentivized me every week
to gives you a reason to play your sides
having to win every single game or get
really sweaty and get really frustrated
six no you win a couple you did really
good here you're something a little you
know I know I'm not you don't need
everyone does need a participation
trophy but if you're putting time in and
you're playing well you know little
gifts but yeah so that that's pretty
much it like I'm definitely hyped about
that I'm hyped about they're bringing
the classic trials weapons back there's
a lot of good weapons now I'm curious if
they do I doubt they'd do it but one
thing with trials had was a element to
primaries I don't think they got to do
that I doubt they'd do that because that
was dead Ellis of they're dead but she
doesn't like to do anymore because I'll
take that bad way to the die forward
harpy but anyway so I don't think they
could Connecticut energy as though yeah
well I think I said we just need you
know our typical day without mercy you
know if you lose you get a chance if you
get one win you get the extra win you
know I'm saying you need I need you need
a little incentivize things and yo
cheatin we got to get that you know the
bad Hammers got to go there
they gotta got that on that's I I played
a lot of PvP I didn't put a lot of comp
this past season but I saw a little bit
I you know watch other people streaming
and I see it and it blows my mind how I
mean I'm not XIV enough to understand
how it all works but when you have
people shooting snipers like they're an
SMG and flying across the rap oh my god
I'm just surprised there's not something
in the game that like immediately like
okay this person is moving way faster
than this set of boundaries mm you know
quick Bantam whatever it needs to be so
I'm hoping I know there's another table
before trials comes out I'm hoping that
in this next blob they're like here's
the whole thing is just like anti-cheat
this is what we're doing yeah probably
one of the biggest things is cheating
cuz at this point yeah and you're the
artifact they just get literal can't
handle certification before the first
week which is fine how are level
shouldn't be too
crazy I mean mm-hmm so be it it's done
it's not perfect but they listen so it's
gonna be there but yeah the cheating is
the biggest thing for people who
especially if they really starts to get
seriously or if you're watching like
streamers getting cheated on and stuff
like like mm-hmm it's gonna be one of
those it's gonna be probably the bigger
thing that takes people away what for
one reason why the boundaries will have
to be there to give you that other side
of alternative for loot rewards in case
like dude I just got like DDoS what the
hell but at least if you get the
bounties it's not completely all for
naught which is good got that mercy yeah
yeah though the balloons the bounty is
definitely gonna be a thing hopefully
there wouldn't worth cheating but it's
like it's just just often have to see
and I always hear people talk about anti
cheat and I just wonder what it is about
not trying to have that in there are
things of that nature so kind of wonder
they ever they do their own and I always
wonder if it just never seems to be
enough moment well I think what it is is
they got to ratchet up the sensitivity
right I think the issue they had at
least the vibe I see from the outside
looking in was they were worried about
false flag right where someone may not
be doing something but from what I was
told you know recently I've got I've
heard of people who have bots or
whatever these things are in other games
try to launch destiny now and niggy and
hit there so apparently whatever this
sensitivity that they've ratcheted it
because I'm hearing reports or reddit
and other things of people saying yo you
know isn't gonna be perfect no people
going to slip through the cracks of
course you know saying but at the end of
the day as long as that level of
sensitivity and I'm here when they get
in the ban or Fripp like here is the
head of warning like stop that cuz we
can't be having it that's going out down
in trials barefoot sure this the stakes
are way too high and that's how it
promotes I mean that the sad brought
about trials you know it promotes like
you know a hold of different subculture
dudes like yo pay me imma take you to
the lighthouse and always because I've
I'm a little I don't know how you feel
about it I I had someone help me yeah
and I I was like all right you know I'm
he's placing a value in this person's
providing a skill it's uh I'm kind of
torn on it even though as someone who
are taking it I wanted at one point mmm
it's weird I am I can see how it
gives up more people to play and it's
you know it's not for me it's just I was
tired of running into three stacks and I
even was like they were messaging me and
I was started joke around like I want
Stroh Rico and he's like yo if you're
serious go to this person's twitch and
I'm like oh Sh I could be here for three
weeks and grind my way by myself and
maybe get it or I can just you know hey
this person some money that they'll be
done in three hours so it's it's a weird
thing it's something new to me did you
beat the kid Nick it was it a money
exchange
oh yeah no yeah no for me as always I've
been paying I never in final fantasy xi
online the first time I ever paid from
in-game currency I was like thinking to
myself I'm like I just spent 20 bucks on
a video game for currency so I'd adjust
all right how long would it have taken
me to get that money in game all right
definitely more than X amount of hours
all right
I worked for this amount of hours to
make this money and I can just pay that
to not have to play the game for x-men
yeah it's a weird thing I don't I'm okay
with it
mm-hmm but it definitely promotes a
weird culture so no now I will say this
like I hear we coming from all I'm
saying is like if dudes doing that
that's their business my thing is to do
I don't mind it I guess if it's done off
the skill if it's somebody say oh I am
dead nice that KD is ridiculous I get
you a dead doing that and do just pay
hey I'm not knocking it also watch that
man's pocket if he's doing it and
legitly all I'm saying is it's the dude
who's out there with the aimbot and all
this other stuff you know or ddossing
and that's gonna come yeah there were
times when you know dude you were
playing I don't know if you remember
this eat you'd play trials and did like
they were booting your teammates out oh
yeah absolutely yeah you just buy
yourself three we won and you like you
know what is going on like I remember
times like that so dudes was really you
know doing some sheisty stuff you know
just where they had just been pure
manipulation as opposed to what Bobby's
saying where someone is really talented
and can carry you're not saying a team
on his own
ya know it's kind of one of those where
I've still always wondered why in
competitive bill oh no is if you drop a
player that is just a substantial
disadvantage I mean yeah people have
come back from 3 V ones cuz they're the
point zero zero one percent the rest of
us normal people are screwed when that
happens because there's too much that is
gonna get against you and if it's if
somebody stays dropped long enough even
if they come back like two rounds later
why should that match at least count
against you
maybe that match can be like hey this is
like if you win it cool but if you lose
it shouldn't count against you win just
like that the system should understand
like yeah or something we're at a
disadvantage do you want to leave this
game and not have account at minimum
there should be something in the
algorithm that after at least two rounds
of a of a complete of a mismatch as far
as player count yeah there should be
something in the algorithm that says
okay this is this the losing team the
winning team can get whatever that you
need on go on
but the losing team should not be either
panel out it should be like honestly or
even just a reward something you gotta
give something to that player because
that is the most demoralizing thing oh
yeah you know I played a bunch of copies
where I was going in solo and you lose
one and then you win a game and you're
in the chair do we got this let's lock
this down and you try but you know
three-on-two advantage it's pretty tough
to say just like the even if it just
says lost waived for mismatch or
something whatever like yeah just
something to acknowledge it because it
happens too often and ddossing with peer
to peer is apparently really really
simple dude I'm pretty sure I was
getting ddosed a month a month or so ago
I was playing and every single time I
would get in a game I'd be kicked and it
kept happening Internet was fine checked
it restarted it it kept happening I'm
like mmm I don't know what's going on
but this is weird
so it's dados got a good point he's
saying I feel people might take
advantage of that I mean listen they've
got and if you're not they gotta do
something
there's a piano I don't know what the
the most fairest thing is I'll say yes I
can't see us a day when someone you know
try may try to exploit that or whatever
whatever but you can't you can't just go
through these matches it has to be some
type of miss me
algorithm it has to be and they they
have to figure they'd have to figure it
out yeah it's it's frustrated or if the
system is able to recognize that you
know you not this specific error it's
like okay this is not baboo and air or
whatever you know that it's cold we're
getting eat offs or whatever maybe it's
alright you know this person got kicked
for this error and like the person
saying your chat there cuz there could
be some sort of you know people take
advantage but yeah
lastly we'll see you know let's just say
that yeah it's like taking advantage you
do think it's like oh we're down breed
there's like five rounds and we're down
three to nothing well I'm gonna turn off
my computer I'll see you guys after the
rounds over so we don't lose this one or
not or something that's and that is a
hard thing because if it is just truly
like you know disconnection or DDoS or
whatever specific their code may not be
able to make the distinction between the
two so that's difficult yeah but it
still sucks for the people who are
actually trying to do it so I don't know
yeah we'll see alright so that does seem
to probably cover the trailer we've got
a couple other teasers in there we have
a captain that is a champion kind of
wondered if you guys thought it was
going to be barrier overload or
unstoppable just Cheerilee curious if
you had an opinion
when he's flipping a hobby the flipping
the exploder shank it's that last spring
okay I I did like those mods they
definitely you know what season the work
worthy did it I didn't have any energy
primaries that I liked now I have like
seven just when cuz of the mods and I
had to switch and say alright here's a
scout here's a pulse here's a bow and it
definitely made me find good rolls on a
bunch of energy primaries so mm-hm
I did like that that was a good mechanic
I think that what you do would you date
it I don't see it being as unstoppable
because I don't see them typically
chasing you captains or weenies they
always run yeah so probably barrier but
if it's a barrier barrier captain that's
also gonna get really annoying cuz he
looks like he's holding almost like a
scorch cannon so and it just sounds like
it's gonna be a painful fight is what
that sounds like
yeah really big the are the artifact
might go cuz was it last season was
solar
focused you know prior to that was to
see think we were ready for Boyd now yes
we have we had more applies this one's
probably gonna be solar an ark yeah okay
we at Arkansas boy alright if they wrote
doing it that way now if they rotate it
I'm curious to see what weapon
archetypes they're gonna try to lean us
into obviously last one with scouts
you know they had Scouts in there and
stuff like that I'm very very curious
about the artefact set up like it I'm
guessing were only done they've only
done primaries they haven't done they
haven't done any sniper Scouts fusions
yeah machine guns like none of that
stuff and they may not want to steer you
into the specials in heavies but I mean
how many primers can you go between is
it gonna be autos sidearms what am I
missing
what have we not really nice yeah I
think we've had we had like autos and
SMGs in the first one we're pretty big
cuz you know recluse was still crazy
popular yes then we got autos a little
bit for mmm-hmm unstoppable I think this
time but then you've got mostly
no they were overload though I mean I
could just see him rotating through it's
like his pulse is coming back don't know
yet
yeah don't know yes I would like there I
like I think it would be cool if they
took some sort of way of you can use
whatever you want to apply mod to it but
this week this element or this type of
weapon is buff so you get you know in a
1.25 multiplier on using autos or mm-hmm
just so you have that ability of like
you know whatever like this gun I'm
gonna use it maybe a little weak than
you but I'm not like breezeless
advantage yep mmm yeah so yeah speaking
of the season past and mods and all that
stuff we do have the website so seasons
are the worthy website pretty much
launched shortly after the trailer so we
know the date is March 10th to June 9th
like dead on three months pretty exactly
this time around mm-hmm they do touch on
a little bit of the story so obviously
they said save the last city with the
sundial freed from the clutches of the
red Legion one escapes island Flair
enacts a desperate ploy for revenge
against the last City guardians of the
light must set aside old differences
again is its avala in an tabret they got
to work together they're the ones the
picture may no need to band together
with an unlikely allies no you value you
as loser to matrix because you paused
you said the must set aside all
differences like drops for a second so
the hiccup in the joys of internet I
guess but good thing I guess I was
talking with my audios there yeah I
basically just read off save the last
city just a piece on the website one big
use just to consider is like
[Music]
band together with unlikely allies
Laurel so yeah like Rasputin's the
obvious one that we're gonna pair up
with but who else me I'm on the old you
tray you know it's got definitely Aldrin
um I don't know it's Rasputin cuz of
allah nana where they got to kind of get
over their stuff of like being different
sides but mutant be an unlikely ally
maybe Aldrin don't know I still see
Aldrin being that teaser cinematic like
in the tower like somebody like he's
sitting there having lunch or something
as avala looks over and it's like just
loses his stuff or something goes to
that could be wool but basically it says
power up rasputin's so we've got time is
running out so you've got save velocity
of course serif towers so join your
fellow Guardians and prepare rasputin's
defense in shared public events now this
is weird because this ease of the towers
we see it in the cinematic trailer it's
got the two towers they're throwing orbs
into it I'm not sure if that's gonna be
like a forge type mechanic where you go
do something throw a ball to start
charging this thing up to finish the
thing but this picture shows it in the
European dead zone on the moon we've
definitely got it in the cinematic 100%
on the game play I don't know how many
places these are gonna be are they gonna
be like new public events all over the
place don't really know and then of
course we're teased with bounties and
bunkers and this is where I guess the
worthy part of Rasputin
rise to Rasputin's challenge and clear
bunkers throughout the system to
re-establish communication with the more
mine and I think you guys were writing
just we do have to face Rasputin's
challenges to prove I guess we might be
worthy to wrest butan so maybe it's a
scenario where all these bunkers is
taken over by all the other enemy
factions saying right go clear this out
of here cuz if we're gonna use these
weapons you got all these guys jamming
my stuff up so it's probably that you my
boy Osiris had to run down on him and
say listen this was sir he acquiesced so
there you go
I'm a little sad as fanboys I'm
completely biased everything was saying
I saw some pretty funny where it was
like Osiris things he can go up to the
war mongers got rifle and take it out
it's like
he's trying listen who's complying
though you see yeah Rasputin's
compliance their card things done for
the for the Guardians mommy
good food okay cool I just want to make
sure stream was back as well don't mean
we've got the Seraph towers we use borer
I guess preparing our students defenses
we got to go clear out the bunkers and
then when we look about the calendar as
well which we can kind of jump to at
least that part of it the calendar we've
got so beginning March 10th the Seraph
tower event of the new PvE activity I've
got new legendary weapons and armor
coming from that also on March 10th and
then this is the way the dates end I'm
guessing they're just all respective
dates March 10th March 24th and April
7th you've got serif bunkers on etz the
moon and io and also States legendary
lost sectors that's a lot of the PvE
kind of story related stuff so yeah I
wanted to get you guys thoughts as we
see that kind of all I can think of a
saurons eye the only thing I can picture
for the two tower blowing thing in the
middle that's that's all I can see so
you have the Sauron eye public event and
you've got these bunkers and then they
did actually clarify the legendary lost
sectors are separate so I wanted to get
you guys thoughts on all of those pieces
of which sponsors what like the sera
it's a seraph bunker II D Z and Moon and
then underneath it says legendary Lost
Urso also dozers are separate yeah yeah
the bunker is not the lost sector like
the bunker is one thing and then maybe
like for the week of March 10th if it's
a DZ loss sectors on etz or legendary
for like the first two weeks maybe
that's kind of the way I read that knows
wonder what you guys thought those might
entail what you think Bobby yeah I the
more I think about it you know it's
funny because we spent a lot of
this past season spent a lot of time in
law sectors finishing bounties so I'm
thinking maybe they want to take that
thought process of alright people are
spending a lot of time in law sectors
doing whatever they got to do make it
more challenging so it'd be cool if it
was solo you go into the solo and it's
like you have no team because it is a
law sector maybe it's you know not as
challenging of activity but yeah I like
I like that I mean I'm all for bringing
in new gamemodes
new types of game modes so hopefully you
know the law sectors are just like a
buffed up version maybe it's solo thing
I think that'd be kind of cool um yeah
Seraph bunker and and then the surf
tower it's uh I like it I've liked all
you know the X offensive was cool I like
all the new stuff that they've they've
been bringing in so I think they keep
try new public type activities and I
started with um what should we call it
and I'm not bars or get Mars the moon
day what was it called the escalation
protocol protocol all right that was
cool
I feel like to keep trying these new
type of public activities that yeah are
you know giving you good rewards so
anything where I can go in that I don't
have to lfg for to get good stuff get
rewards I'm down for that
yeah listen I mean you know I like
things like this you know I like when
you they have basically you go back to
older spaces and they have newer things
in the older space to encourage it so I
like that aspect um I like the fact that
it all looks like most sectors are gonna
get some love I've always liked loss
sectors you don't say I always thought
there with coop like the ones on the
moon we're really well done
you know see I really enjoyed those are
amazing all of our great yeah the mole
loss sectors are amazing I'm very
curious to see what the actual gameplay
loop how they handle the difficulty is
it just gonna be a B for your boss is
there gonna be mechanics with the loss
sector you know what yeah like what's
gonna separate it from just the everyday
lost sector so that that yeah if they
had my barrier stuff and all that I
wouldn't I wouldn't mind it you know I'm
saying like if they had that kind of
stuff it definitely needs to be more
interesting
you know saying so that's what I think
again and this word comes back to risk
versus reward like if this thing wants
to kick my butt in lost sector why am I
gonna do it what's gonna be in a lost
sector that says hey I need to go in
this cave but it rewards need to be
better we gotta get some shards some
golf balls or something you know so yeah
I would hope that the reward system is
there then I from my understand I know
I'm going ahead with the talk for my
understanding pinnacle right stuff what
gets there yeah like we'll get there boy
yeah we've been alluded to pinnacle
stuff so yeah I'm actually I'm more
excited about this I'm curious about
this particularly as opposed to we'll
get to the next thing with the ordeal of
all that that's where I'm at
yeah I know for me I mean the public
events I think people were like hey how
about he's gonna ether I was in the
matrix now yeah Bobby's in the matrix
yeah anymore he did we go flee to get
him back yeah hold off hopefully totally
lost him let him he lost me I think he
dropped but hopefully we get Bobby back
yep we'll hold off for a second guys
mhmmm I'm using the matrix
our faces are a little off-putting now
this is all gay
mmm-hmm no difficulties of a live show
you're correct
okay yeah he's good he's good he said he
got ddosed oh my god hey no no four
trials where he started early with my
boy oh good hey give him just a second
guys they'll be back soon
oh so I'm gonna continue I just want a
rock out why don't you two wait
we just wait like in you no no no he's
come it may be a low I he said he had a
restart his internet now that's okay I
mean you and I can hang out for a second
I just much did not try and like cut
this audio out of the middle probably
works for a good point so yeah alright
hey I'm telling you I just got someone
that just sits in my house and they're
like alright something important is
happening deal shutdown cuz I look at my
internet I call off the moon they're
like no we have no problems and it's
like I don't know alright yeah they
practice a ddos dedos an EVP people did
like all this lost sector talk but we
back we back we back up into bill good
we got no doubt give me a little break
but they're right you said you've
restarted your computer no I have to
restart so yep audio is still going all
that was we get nice okay yes so for me
basically what I was gonna say is like
they were getting to a point where I
think people were gonna start to get
tired of how many more of these six per
student match main activities are we
gonna do season after season and this
seems like a different way to kind of
break it up
different bunkers on different locations
with lost sectors and then public events
just as a little variety from Lake was
it gonna be I mean the sundial was cool
honestly I'd love to see that thing as a
strike just cuz it's a fun bro McCain of
yeah through and I did wish it wouldn't
leave and they've even said they don't
want stuff to leave and the more public
events I guess development wise for them
it's probably a little easier to create
public events in a space that already
exist as opposed to making a brand new
sundial or vex offensive space yeah
because I mean we have escalation
protocol still that's slow going on so I
guess maybe this is something I can be
around for longer yeah yeah yeah so then
we've got the bunkers which again
probably are gonna be smaller and
reusing lost sectors just with kind of
like Reese kins and this is where like
some people may be like well hey I've
already played these lost sectors before
it's like well again were there where we
still have to consider their bandwidth
and how much they can create in a
certain amount of time as we get to this
and overall again I think it will be
cool like
just the rewards gonna need to be there
you got the buggers the law sectors
ain't a different public event night
follower deals you could pick this thing
apart and see that it might feel light
but again I'm more interested in the
story and I think that's what's gonna
take me through the season more than
anything
real quick e this would be a perfect way
because we know the whole controversy
with the artifact is that people like to
form the law sectors right so this could
be a perfect opportunity for them to
scale XP down in the regular law sector
yeah and then use the legendary like if
you really wanna form
you gotta form this version to get that
same level what I think that's how they
can handle artifact balance long term
for people who just want to kind of get
in there and grind and cheese that out
just to blaze up their artifact level
because there's be really they're aware
for the fact that they made that whole
thing you know last minute you know what
we're gonna disable it you know I know
we get into the trouble you'll get into
it but to me that's them one listener
community to analyzing the patterns of
what we're doing you know I'm saying
they have the metrics they have the
analytics right there so it's it's
easily them saying okay you know what
they say what we intended for you to be
Fitbit going in and out a lot like this
that's this whole season was me grabbing
bounties go into loss sector complete
the value switch my character treatments
repeat and I'm like alright I'm done
I don't need Iran it was just you know I
felt it was weird it was for me this
season was very much season the solo
player I could do everything so the only
thing I had to do was lfg for the
legendary son diamond house no wasn't
that challenging I did in the first run
with an elephant no confession very
simple so I I mean I enjoyed it cuz it
felt like I could play the game pretty
passively and still get a lot of good
stuff out of it but I don't think that's
good for the game hey you want to do all
the stuff and get all these weapons well
you can just go do it by yourself and do
the same wall sector a thousand times
yes the tower slot machine is is just an
example of something it'd be like hey
you wanted to crap a little weapons yeah
this isn't feel great though some people
may be like well I got all my weapons it
was so easy it's like yeah but do you
feel any gratification while you set
their engine with the button right no
was the event itself like cool yeah
building it up and all that stuff but
yeah yeah 50,000 Franklin later I'm like
I just want to go in the other room now
is it here I was like and I have like
90,000 to turn in and I'm like do I want
the shot or not I don't know if I can
put my gonna let them all go to the
waste them all not don't do it again
it's just demoralizing how slow that is
it takes so much time
yeah why is that why is the turn in not
like three times it's a hundred how much
can you see by doing Muhammad they
should have been like click for every
like thousand ten thousand want to
donate I won donate fifty thousand click
it boom yes you sure boom done but they
should have had look at one hundred four
hundred and maybe like a thousand or
nine nine nine nine like four different
shows do you want to do you want to dump
go get your four out of the way mmm I
don't know that was their tracking
back-end couldn't keep up with all the
stuff that they've got to watch like
number wallet slice and put this in a
database and all this stuff like it may
have been harder and that's why they had
to do hundreds but man that's rough man
oh yeah it was rough uh so we got
but yeah the PP stuff look PvE stuff
looks like it's got at least cool
potential we'll see how the story
progresses along trials begins on the
13th we know that is the only week where
the artifact power will be active after
that it's gone so returns every week if
you guys think it'll be Friday through
Sunday or Friday through Monday the way
certain balls what did he used to be
used to be Friday food Monday
yeah I think they like certain yeah it
was always I think it was kind of like
synonymous or my gut says Monday yeah
we'll see what we see Friday noon
through Monday at noon basically saying
72 million basically yeah but since that
sounds like a good time for me we got a
new seal I think people thought that
that might be called flawless because
the trailer I've seen that floating
around that's kind of a cool title and
of course they got your Jeff in themed
armor Magneto's their dress like Anubis
and he's gonna be a hundred percent
happy what so ready so ready I mean
their warlock helm is so bad where I
need that yeah I am a big fan of Titan
at least this Titan armor looks pretty
good yeah they're gonna go for something
this one not the
not the straightjacket we get later on
oh that's fine hmm we've got three maps
so we know travels osiris returns I'm
trying to read your everything we know
iron banner is gonna be around
and honestly nice the artifacts gonna be
turned off for that so I'm kind of
amulet balance yep not so crazy to go
and be like why is that dude 995 and I
can't punch him oh that's why yeah
ESMA mm-hmm so the other two big ones
we've kind of got this season broken up
into kind of two-week segments March
10th to 23rd seems like the Seraph
bunker on the ii DZ and you've got March
24th through April 6th the Seraph bunker
on the moon and los sectors April 7th
that's like so four weeks later we got
the theraph bunker and los sectors on Io
and then two weeks after that we don't
have anything else for bunkers or
anything so maybe that's the next like
phase of the story we'll see it's like
the three bunkers and stuff
Grand Master ordeal new nightfall strike
difficulty new seal and therefore title
in Ind game rewards hmm
now we've talked about this before
probably the last time I spoke about it
at nauseam I'm sure but and Bob for you
what do you think when it comes to a
grand master or a deal for one how it
can set itself apart and to what the
rewards could be
yeah I I like this I think I I'd like
that what they did with the new
nightfall and how everything the changes
they did with that um this feels kind of
like something for the raid people you
know that they want to be challenged in
that PvE mm-hm
I didn't I do enjoy I did enjoy watching
people do the you know the 98 night
polls for a while that was really
challenging would eventually people just
became too powerful right
um reward wise yeah I hope I hope
they're really really PvE focus weapons
I really hope they nail that down where
its crucible weapons are super good and
crucible they're not something you know
you don't get like a recluse that's the
best gun in PvE so I really are specific
yeah obviously hoping for new perks
that'd be nice it's a more specific PVE
pvp perks you know don't need a whole
table of them but a couple new ones
would be nice you know they did it this
year with morale and a couple other
things um yeah I just I that's all I'm
hoping for is that they're specific so
that you know you're a PvE person you
want to go grind every week and do this
and just get the best bvu weapons so
that you know you can go back to the old
breeds whatever you want to do yeah I'm
looking forward to it I I'll go in there
every now and then when I get a couple
player you know a couple new people
together go challenge it so
no no don't uh I'm actually just waiting
for you for this I don't have anything
to say I'm a Yankee I said I'll be
waiting for you on this part cuz I mean
very curious like this is his bag this
is your bag so what I saw it is I was
like I just want to hear what you gotta
say because I know how he feels well
about rewards and nightfalls I would
like these oh yes part of my question to
you Bob was uh you got the end of the
rewards and I was like different perks
something specifically helpful in like
your night falls or PvE definitely needs
to not be like like the switch like
recluses great in PvE even like Wyatt
like give me something good and strikes
but as you sit here and I think about
the master level night falls at 980 now
we'll get to the swamp where we're going
above that and this is probably part of
it but mm-hmm
there are eight modifiers on a master
nightfall and they all work against you
oh yeah right
next you're champions you're locked
loadouts you've got extinguish on
everyone the pushback is even farther
and Boyd's in since all basic mobs
exploded leave fire on the ground like
nothing nothing works in your favor and
I'm going yeah are you just gonna attack
like two or three more on and just make
this like the seal should probably be
called masochist at that point because
like seriously I don't I mean for me
night fault like 980 night falls with a
good group of people who are leveled
yeah they're doable but for the average
first and they look at it go huh
we have to make it a step above and to
make a seal behind it I'm like if you
put strike exclusive light behind here
I'm gonna punch somebody cuz if you're
gonna put it behind that level of thing
finally when people been asking for it
forever that's gonna get a little
annoying the seal I don't even know is
it gonna be time trials is it's just
gonna be not die is it gonna be finish
everything knows but ya know I am
against mass he's against it he's black
I'm a store deal yo Bob you were between
us on this banana just punch over the
pulled on where's
we go fight over there seriously though
like I wanted to know if I want to know
how they're gonna make them difficult
and not just painful cuz you can only
make things so much more ridiculously
unreasonable until it's just kind of
like why so I'm just kind of I'm very
curious as to what they do on this one
and I hope they make it a little bit of
fun a little bit of give and take like
give me some buff like whether it be
like specialist their small arms give me
oh ye ones easy mode confirmed where
should be like you know pick up an
orbiter 10 seconds it's easy
listen Luke listens to him so I would
look if you listen to the show you
always do it was retiring he now he
wants an easier mone he's fielded the
deck is stacked too much against him and
he needs a buff so Luke you heard it
here first
implement that in the next file so he
could be good to go cuz you know he
misses de vacas there should be some
sort of like this was the game momentum
there should be some sort of buff that
you know kill X amount of enemies in a
row you know you get a multiplier
something that you have to activate
instead of being able to just pick your
loadout pick the buffs big rookie buffs
and alright we got that we know how to
do this active things within the within
the nightfall that right let's say
you're taking too long
alright things are getting harder you're
cruising through it you're doing really
good you're stacking things up keep you
know keep buffing me keep off me until I
until I die or mess up so look like that
like a momentum kind of thing where he
is like a bar atop it's like alright you
know it starts in the middle and you're
progressing at the normal rate if you
start flying through it it's alright you
know we're gonna keep buffing you're
doing really good you playing louder
than Ward yuka playing bad well it's
only gonna get harder so something like
that we had a quad I could work with
that I get that yeah that because it's
incentive to not just lollygag you can't
just sit back and snipe it's gonna in
cinemas you to stay active as you said
which is yeah what they want they don't
want people to sit back and snipe so
it's like alright well make me get up in
the mix don't make it don't make it be
like 1,000 1,100 power level where I
just
like looking things and they kill me but
yeah yeah there's that that'll be the
balance with the parallel one we'll talk
about or they could actually make those
damn Mazda they introduced more
practical for those things those it
there's something of like the charge
with light are denied how yeah how about
those actually you're not saying that
they're ineffective but have it where it
really has a benefit and knows most so
that you actually spec your guardian
with them so that it's beneficial for
high-level activity because let's be
real you know if you're gonna spend
these things cost a lot of um you know
the energy they want you to commit so if
you're gonna commit to that it would be
nice to have some type of benefit you
know in those type activity so let's see
I'm very curious so I was very curious
how he felt about it yeah I just want to
see how they implement it because if
it's just like hey let me start 12 more
modifiers that suck on there that just
gets to be unfun for everybody so at
some point as you said like incentive to
be more active to get a little bit at
still punishing if you like if you
messed up but some balance in there to
make it unique because you know
grandmaster can't just can't just
completely step on you like a bug yeah I
know and then the final one that I think
has everybody intrigued Guardian games
so no no more revelry so no more
infinite forest repeats hopefully which
they make it is probably okay with guys
the last competition which I think
they're kind of getting into this whole
crayon eating fluffing competition and
then new legendary armor to go with that
so I want to get you guys thoughts on
this one because it's April 21st same
time is grandmaster ordeal for about
three weeks I don't know why don't last
three weeks but again it's in this game
seem to last three weeks so thoughts on
it I think it's really cool I think you
know you're always getting people saying
oh you're this mean or you play this you
know brain eaters blah I really hope
that maybe it's like alright all you
know it's maybe there's a PvP element or
it's like you're Titan you're gonna play
with other Titans against other warlock
a little hot doors or you do a challenge
or even something like yeah but it's
like you go with all Titans you know
something like that where it's fun it's
light-hearted but you know you're
warning it's it's what it all comes down
to is
if you give people rewards to chase and
they're good they're gonna get it so I
hope that is really like you know you
play with what your classes and you you
really come up and you figure things out
because each class you know they all
have some classes that are very
different so you can you know you can go
three of each class and do an activity
or something like that I'm excited for
it I will definitely be a proud Titan
trying to do it there we go I got
another crayon eater with more Becca
crayon sharpener in the back of the box
we'll be ready to go so will proudly be
using my Titan as much as I can and I'm
not having to switch over for whatever
reasons that may may be yeah this sounds
cool I'm excited to wear it I hope
there's some some cool merch and swag
that we can get so we can rock our class
proudly mmm
don't encourage him Bobby oh god this is
cool I mean this seems light hearted it
like Bobby said it seems fun it seems
something like that the bug-out way like
so I like the idea that I like the whole
I like the whole little Olympics kind of
a vibe with the big now what I was
hoping for I know this may be asking too
much but you know what I miss MIT this
would be a cool way to introduce Spyro
racing Olympics USA so like they'd be
different events you know with the tight
track suit I want the tight tracks would
come back I will I dude I had like top
5% times in Sparrow racing league I love
barrel racing like but if you think
about the bandwidth that I have for a
season making something like hey there's
this thing you go play or other
activities and we'll track it like you
need event versus let me go build tracks
and everything else yeah that that
development resource is not gonna happen
I'm just saying I wish - I wish -
somatically right it feels like the
Olympics so how cool would it be if
there were of eights right hey you let's
really do these go to you games even if
you like have to show off your jumping
skills like which place was the most
genuine in that one which have the best
mobility and pretty
I'm usually always in the front man I
use my hammer strike to move around a
lot so now if it came down to a slap in
the contest you know who got the long
range with every character you can all
jump you just have to learn how to do it
yeah it's a floof game honestly you guys
like oh you flip it I'm like you get the
easiest landing like here's this lake
it's like the old love what does the
game we're using had to slowly land on
that like flat part it's like yeah what
is the lunar lander from lake well you
know a Chari or something no no this is
where you're right
the Warlock jump is good for descending
by descending or something you can yeah
you can control yep going up I can
that's the hardest class to jump to and
you're like oh crap I'm dead yeah and
thank God they added mantle in d2 but d1
I was having nightmare
the rainbow all right Cobb we gotta wait
for Cognito because I would be a
detriment to every ray team in any
jumping puzzle it wasn't that bad like I
would it was awful I'm just glad at
least they added mantling indeed that'd
be cool I think I think a movement based
challenge would be cool like a time
thing where you have to go get orbs or
whatever it may be and you know muscle
jumping and whatnot so yeah there's
definitely a lot of in game mechanics
that aren't shooting and using your
abilities that they can do with this so
should be cool I'm excited for it oh
yeah oh yeah let's get excited for you I
go for it it was like it could be fun I
know for it I just hope they execute on
it better than some other things that
they've tried before so hopefully this
one hands out pretty well other things
on the website we've got kind of scroll
back up cuz we jump down to the calendar
for a second yeah trials itself we do
know power levels 960 at a minimum to
get in we know it way to play they've
mentioned there's gonna be a quest
involved and then rewards they said get
multiple wins to earn pinnacle rewards
that's gonna big wins seven in a row to
earn additional rewards and special
access to the lighthouse so mmm-hmm
lighthouse still there seven not nine so
unless it's the bones or bounties or
whatever
um and then get multiple wins there in
pinnacle year so we do have at least
account confirmation of Pinnacle gear do
you think also I hope they do something
with regards to like shards and prisons
often PV because they get they got to
get some place to get those there be
really we got we got average this is it
has to be the pinnacle you know do we
miss we even talk about the swag doe do
we told us why of the handles Hatton pen
I need when do you know gets a different
voice and you know he's getting into it
so but not swag its swag swag I can't
even say it that way but I told you
anything hears about they Bobby oh yeah
yeah bro I'm gonna be living in the
Bungie store yeah I am with that Osiris
logo lighthouse stuff browser every bit
of gear is purchased everybody I looked
up how much I've spent on rewards and
it's a lot I it's a good thing I didn't
get as many seals unlocked as I did
because I would have I would have bought
them all yes yeah I I will very happily
spend my money on things that I love the
aspect of earning something in-game and
then getting in real life it's just I'm
looking at all my little mini guns that
I got over there and it's like yeah give
me more give me more though would you
say he's talking about Caesar I don't
even remember now
that's so good so I was gonna say I
think I saw somebody on Twitter like pan
through their closet of how many shirts
they had then I counted my nose like
crap I have more yeah I got a lot I have
a lot of shirts I do yeah I got a good
amount of shirts I got I know I got the
check that I know the best you know but
he was just shipped out so I got that
bingo on the buns rewards like I can get
this how much is it I am a warm blooded
person in general like I freeze my wife
anybody I'm ever working around so for
me like long sleeves is aa rough now
this one actually is a zipper yeah which
is kind of like theoretically one I
would consider doing so I've actually
thought about that one but I haven't
pulled the trigger on it yet but yeah
like I don't usually do hoodies because
I definitely don't want anything over my
head but
least it's a zipper so I would like
actually concern I live in hoodies my
wife likes to make fun of me because I
like to sleep in a hoodie and I put it
on a bundle yeah I'm all about hoodie so
they can keep me I sleep in as little as
possible with one leg out of the sheets
so yeah I got yeah my bottom half is is
not and then finally we got everything
with the season pass so we've got season
pass owners weekly rasputin challenges
yes that might either be the towers or
the bunkers or who knows separate
legendary lost sectors its own bullet
points who got that a new exotic quest
line hmm wanted to ask if you guys think
it's fourth Horseman or crazy cabal good
for the quest cabal too just because of
the Cabal themed of them like coming
back against us like that cuz it's the
new one but I have this weird feeling
like fourth Horseman because it's I hope
it's a one of my greatest destiny
moments was when forsaking launch played
it for like 17 18 hours got to the Ace
of Spades quest mm-hmm like probably two
or three in the morning need my friends
like do we do this and I'm like yeah
let's do it we did the whole quest got
Asus page that first night that was dope
Thorne was a good quest last word was a
good quest I like exotic quest that are
memorable Devil's ruin that was like meh
yeah Bastion and will I just hope it's
fun I hope it's challenging I like when
they make you do a lot of different
things as long as they're you know
attainable good who's Annie ah then
we've got instantly unlocked the 7th
Seraph armor so we do have this so for
armor sets we've got a couple you've got
your base set of armor kind of free
access it's got the mostly just kind of
darker almost dark grey if not black
with kind of a yellow accents just kind
of looks like war mindish you've got the
ornaments which i think are gonna be the
green and like almost like white what
are you thinking about those yomo doubt
about that hunter life and i go hunter
looks good titan frog face is a little
weird
yes
knowingly he's like I got my shoulder
pads in and his shoulder pads are so
beefy what about you warlock over there
how you feeling
oh I like the jeweled face of I'm
feeling very ornate yeah I like that you
got I'm saying look I got to a good
sheet on it you know saying put off
that's okay I don't know about the
bottom half as much I got to see how a
lot of legs go down but we're in a dress
all the time anyway that shouldn't be
new so you see this land you see this oh
my dress dress is the first time I
literally threw my crayon ass under the
bus though your face so I like you know
I like the different armor I always feel
like I have a good amount of armor like
every season like all right I got cool
armor it's really dope so mm-hmm looks
good I'm it'll be you know you always
see the shade that it comes in default
but then you start necessarily oh and
look it this looks great so mm-hmm
looks have to be honest oh I like the
arm the free to all destiny players
warlock arm cuz that feel like some
comandante joint you got - I got the
little sash you know I'm saying yeah dad
joint feels like I'm a lieutenant like
I'm just gonna say it looks very
militaristic yeah like that style home
the Warlock top
I guess the Titans in the middle yeah
okay so hunters yeah I love that is kind
of the big tie-in for like the colors on
the gray and white especially you throw
a shader on there but that's like that's
a Russian military but colors my brother
I think you somebody pointed out to me
so you got that one you got the military
look for the straight set both look kind
of cool for sure and then we got if our
frog face that I kick thing down oh I'm
sure yeah and I saw where it's basically
like Master Chief's helmet just cut the
face off that's pretty much I've seen a
lot of memes on that helmet yes yes I'll
get it Bradley now thoughts from you
Bobby on this one I've probably said
mine my share instantly unlock the
exotic auto-rifle Tommy's matchbox yeah
you know it's I guess it's a I don't
know I would I don't like getting it
automatically it doesn't you know you
see people get all let me get it and
then that allure of trying to earn
something goes away you have it I don't
know I don't like getting just being
given something especially an exotic yes
so you know put a little question there
make it go do something real quick oh
thank you go kill a little boss at least
something to make you earn it
or some part of the story where you got
a you know earn it but uh yeah it's it
is what it is you know it's nice to get
right away but at the same time it just
takes away from that earning but she
brings that damn exotic yeah it just
cheapens in a bit but yeah we we all
agree on that one that's pretty sad yeah
I mean it's at level 35 in the season
pass for the other side I mean they get
it then even if it was later in the
season I would probably still be more on
board just like she log in exotic like
that you did exotic in the first minute
if you want it I'm just like that's
that's too much yeah I think they had
done that in the past couple seasons to
reward new players or people that did by
the seasons like hey by season you get a
really cool gun right away and that you
know it's a selling point it's they show
it and you're like alright you you pay
for it you get it right away but yeah it
definitely feels a little cheap a little
just like you didn't not earn it but
hopefully there'll be some sort of
little quest to go with it you exchanged
$10 for this exotic here you go doesn't
have to be crazy go shoot one guy in the
face just Rob who knows a quick little
like lost sector equivalency quests or
you know and you should get the quest
for it yeah you can do solo maybe even
it's like old content where you have to
go back like I don't know do the arms
dealers strike or something in that
range read yep some like a great but
just unlocking it
yeah day what I hate that but we've said
we've talked about this everything else
we're getting you know cosmetics emotes
triumphs all that stuff will be in there
for all players we've got to fin the
last city from the red Legion by
powering up Rasputin's it's the towers
to the public events not entirely sure
how that's gonna go if it's gonna be
like a trackable thing we're building it
up over time or it's just like six weeks
later it's active who knows the new
serifs are public events and bunker
activities
he's an artifact we know these enormous
that's all that stuff's about the same
so that pretty much covers this you
worthy page you can scroll through the
season pass I will say I know this is
the third time they're doing the season
pass it's not a bad thing it's just like
an extra bonus but I would like to see
them mix it up a little more when it
probably comes to year for probably not
gonna see a whole lot between now and
season 10 but I wanna I want to refresh
on the season pass because it's it's
ornaments a little bit of currency it's
couple sets armor and it's a dreams and
that's it and I'm like I don't know what
else I I haven't thought like just
almost the ranks are identical Crowley I
don't know just you get a couple weapons
in there we know I I can almost tell you
what its season 11 is gonna be a night
oh and we're not even there yet it's
almost the same here's your little
experience buffs here's a couple
ornaments here's a couple armor sets I
mean yeah it's fine I guess I don't know
it's it's an extra value it doesn't hurt
anything I just I would like to see them
just evolve it near for take what do you
know take feedback I don't see it for
most people that played a lot it all
this is very attainable and then once
you get everything you're like oh I just
completed all this stuff and I got
everything it's like all right
that doesn't my season rank doesn't even
matter once a 100 I think I'm like 242
now so be cool if you could reset get it
again do different stuff but uh yeah I
mean I like it I think I like the model
of what I really liked was getting armor
drop so you know you go to your alt boom
you have mom and you can just quickly
catch up level that was a nice little oh
no aspect of it but yeah I need any
evolution on it would be cool or
continuation of it or restart and
getting stuff again or get more
materials or more exotics or that equal
if maybe you get you know every 10 or 20
levels after 100 you get to get another
guaranteed exotic that's I know they
said in the table but they're gonna come
with higher stat roles so maybe
something like that or you know I know
we get today yeah they definitely did
talk about that yeah I mean it's kind of
funny because I was very you know II
knows I was very wary of the whole
battle past a 20 years was announced and
I'm I gonna be fortnight and we'll be
doing and I'm saying and and I gotta
admit it
it's been pretty harmless about
nothingness the exotic giving away yeah
a new freebie yeah yeah yeah - - how's
my boy Sione door was in the chat he
said he wants a quest law and commitment
to make that exotic special trip I'm
with you brother you know I'm with you
you know I mean so you know that that's
the only complaint but to be I go a lot
I'll be like him when I sometimes I'm
going that upgrade module you all or new
resource and that low check come in come
full-circle babe I do like getting those
do those resources yeah I think it's
great for resources yeah like you get
the upgrades though alt like after a bun
30 most of it shuts down - yeah cuz 30
is like you get the upgrade modules for
a couple rings you get like what I'm
like seven or eight of those but then
after that man after like 35 especially
because like the free pass totally shuts
down after 35 and then it's at that
point armor sets and charts and basic
stuff but even the upgrades like the
upgrades could blow it in you all right
a little bit I'm taco I'm not gonna lie
I'll be incentivized like number one
shadow keep the this season um we had
the VEX looking ornament armor and I was
looking at my list how far my way from
North how far my with the almond is kind
of cool
it does incentivize me yeah gotta grind
I grind it hard this season to get to I
think was 92 where you could get to perk
slot drops yeah I went nuts and I got
there you know pretty quickly and then
after that you're like okay what do I do
now but yeah it was it's good I think
it's good it's not harming anything it's
not changing anything up but I think it
would be cool if you know once you do
get through a hundred there's more
exotics there's more resources and
mm-hmm just more stuff yeah don't post a
hundred for those who are hardcore yeah
given just a little something extra even
would be a good evolution of like just
that continuation as opposed to just
every three levels
cosmetic either dagger but no I've come
full circle but a most part I guess I
just get rid of that damn exotic from
the rip and I'm good
so finally we get to the 12 so we've got
one big piece shoutout to Bungie
especially with the basically just with
coronavirus going out there right now
and especially as it you know kind of
started to be a big deal up in Seattle
they've worked pretty hard and from what
I've heard pretty quick to be able to
make a lot of things accessible not
everything you can't do motion capture
at home but yeah like everything
possible to be at Lake development or
testing a lot of things being able to
test things do things at home so people
don't have to travel into the office and
can stay home I mean I've heard I was
listening to DCP and they were saying
you know Microsoft and other things up
there they just straight shut down for
like two and a half weeks like no one is
going into the office to try and give
things time to either not spread or do
what they need to do and it's just nice
to see bungees still doing more and more
things to always stand behind their
employees which always again just sets
them one not one more tear above many
other developers to say hey we care
about our employees where their patches
are a little slower weather you know
fixes are not gonna be quite as quick
just bear with us while you know we're
doing what we can to take care of
employees cuz you know half the office
getting sick everybody's good so yeah
that's the thing is is communication and
they've done a lot they've done a great
job of communicating what they're doing
what's going on with the game and just
hey we need one more time things might
be coming out as fast like you said so
yeah definitely props to them for not
being so focused you know on the
business monetary side of it and be like
alright we're people too we got to take
time we can't be just going nuts and
obviously with the corona virus you
don't want to take any chances so yeah
good on them and not only are they
giving people time off but there or not
time off but you know work from home you
can still do yourself stuff
mm-hm and and respect to them for but
donate and we have to be sensitive also
to the point that they made in reference
to patch Kade it's you know and people
are working from home and stuff like
that you know there may be some little
delays a little bit with with Katie's
and it's understandable I mean look your
lives you know on the line you got to
protect them so salute the flow for
Bungie for you know offering these
options for their employees and just
kind of jumping ahead of it's pretty
cool
now we get into some fun topics oh yeah
the first one is Howard Gaines so they
know previously as we went from you know
nine fifty-nine sixty winnow 960 970 now
they're changing it up and I literally
it was recording a video and this just
like I recorded the video like how to
prepare for season Authority I'm like
stockpile your bad news if you want to
artifacts not gonna matter it's only
gonna help you in your season pass you
could go do pinnacles but as I saw on
Twitter Kosmos like hey we'll talk about
the swallows like I have this weird
suspicion it's not gonna be just ten
levels it's not so I said it was like
you could grind pickles or you could
wait till Thursday to see if there's a
reason to grind pinnacles yeah not so
much so this is kind of what I've seen
both sides of so let me kind of explain
it and we'll talk about it so they are
raising the cap for gear drops 40 points
powerful gear will not now drop up to a
thousand from 960 pinnacles are going up
to 1010 soft captain of everything blues
just the world is gonna be dropping up
to 950 as well so getting up to 950 will
be quicker we do know 960 is also where
trial starts so yeah basic stuff gets
you there you do have to do some
powerful 's to get to 960 so making
those new characters and stuff takes a
little bit to get in there and they said
they're also looking to make some
quality of life updates in the pinnacle
band starting to point 8.1 which
honestly I imagine is right in line with
the Grandmaster because it says mid
season and that's like six weeks then
mm-hmm we'll be upgrading some existing
powerful rewards to pinnacle pinnacle
upgrading powerful rewards to Pinnacle
rewards these these are the weekly
crucible strike and gambit challenges as
well as the weekly clay and Ingram with
this change we want to increase that old
number pinnacle pinnacle our sources in
the game broaden pinnacle drop access as
well as increase the pool of items that
can drop in the pinnacle band blot
imbalances can also affect pinnacle
progression what we when we say slot and
balance this could be explaining those
times you have a chess piece to the
drops few times in a row I think the big
ones people getting like twelve energy
weapons in a row so yeah we've been
looking yeah we've been looking at
player feedback for some time and
investigating a few approaches to the
problem space for the Blake
it bounces we're looking to have an
update but that'll probably be at a
later date so that's that's kind of the
big big one for kind of season to season
change first so what do you guys think
mm-hmm Bobby I love it you're just
giving me more reason to go out there
and try and raise my power I love when
everything drops matters and you have to
think strategically do I want to boost
this am I just gonna hold on to this so
I like the gap I like you know getting
40 more points that's great that just
means everything for the first couple
weeks it's gonna matter when Jo I enjoy
the power grind it gives me a reason to
play everything yeah I think the numbers
good I really like that they're adding
pinnacle rewards to more activities that
is big and we need so I was I won't get
too off-topic up I basically had an idea
where you could take bounties and give
them multipliers for different events
raids an EVP etc where you do a specific
activity you get a better reward so I
think this is a step in the right
direction where they're giving
everything a reward you know you're a
beautiful person
you'll get rewards you're a strike
person whatever candidate so that's cool
and I have you know the slot imbalances
I'm sure we've all dealt with you know
getting the same friggin thing again and
again and again so hopefully I was
hoping that they would give you some
sort of choice and it's like all right
your helmet and your power weapon are
the two highest things you can select
something from each other slot there's
just something like that where you know
the RNG will play an aspect there so you
want easy orangey Bobby's not always
safe I just don't want I just wasted
three hours and all and I went up by one
point and I got seven energy weapons in
a row just it gets you that frustration
where you're like why did I just spend
three hours and then you come back and
do it again but I'm going to be messing
with you does letting some sort of
direction where you can you know I don't
want to be able all right I need an
energy weapon boom I get know driven but
at least some sort of way that you can
see that what your highest is is not
gonna get there yeah I'm sorry you
played that up you plead that I sounded
like ezr a Jew but you know no I don't
know I don't want to be handed my power
I guess
I don't think here's the best weapons in
Armour but you know some sort of options
of choice and that remove at least your
highest weapon your highest armor you're
not gonna get that food I'm like
basically a little protection yeah
small small RNG protects you fit now
that's fear that's it just a little bit
just so you know people that don't have
what do I have one thousand five hundred
and fifty two hours of destiny so far so
people don't have that kind of time to
play they can hop on for an hour at
night and gain some power and all right
cool i spent my hour well i did this
this and this i saw gains maybe one
thing didn't go up whatever but there's
been times where i logged on to three
hours goodbye
okay i'm doing the power grind and
nothing happens and you're like well
that was great did all your pretty cool
see like damn I got nothing yep I need
it not yet after you get the same stuff
back to back and it's like enough listen
I'm I was surprised I was surprised with
this I did not think we would get this
big of a jump
Bobby kind of nailed some things um that
I want to say which is pretty much I do
miss the power granny I do miss it man I
do miss that feeling of having to get
stronger to you know to do activities
and prior with the +10 only I had no
incentive it was just like it doesn't
matter you know I'm not really
prohibited for much you know I like the
idea that trials is 960 you know I'm
gonna have to put in a little work to
get in there you know I'm saying and
also to discourage people from cheating
and making new accounts no no you I had
to grind a little bit you got to grind
you have to get in there you know if you
want to do your foolery you have to do
something so that's the first thing the
key thing for me and and you know Bobby
said it well the pinnacle drop sources
that has been a huge problem I've always
hated the fact that when the season
content comes out it was only the new
activity that had it you know only the
raid and again as a PvP player there's
nothing more frustrating than really not
having that so obviously we new trials
is coming that's gonna have it they're
saying it's spreading spreading it out
you know other activities well I think
kind of what Luke's we've said in the
director's cut before core activities
two things that we really play all the
time the crucible the gambit strikes you
know all they nasally plays they -
they're like hey you wanna get the seal
you want to get this stupid little badge
you gotta go spend you know ten hours
and like get me needed to happen
Pinnacle's you know in theory were cool
but the way they were distributed was
flawed so now this is the better way to
handle it I'm excited about that um I
like that they even touch don't slot
imbalance
I think that that is a cool thing
because again when the pinnacles are
locked into the raid you know I'm saying
or whatever whatever and you you you're
not getting a heavy or you're not
getting this and you're not getting that
that's frustrating that makes a person
and say I am NOT what what am I gonna
grind for I'm never mean I'm not getting
anything you know I want so this is good
this is a good step I doubt this is a
pleasant surprise
this almost feels like a mini expansion
with the amount of grind you know
nothing pure content you know max
one-to-one but the amount of run I like
a forty to fifty point let's go it's
gonna make me invest yeah you know so
that's where I'm at well you I've got
both sides basically and know basically
the big thing for me is that if you
think of the true hardcore yes what do
you say your value of the pinnacles are
now cuz now they're up to the point
they're plus two people already say the
people who are somewhat hardcore players
who do raids who do dungeons who do play
a lot that pinnacle is now twice as easy
to get to you're gonna get like three or
four more sources now the plus twos
people say make it go old for quick and
then you've got that side of yeah you
get up to a thousand then you get to a
thousand ten now that this is kind of
the weird line they're trying to walk
they make it easier to get to now almost
too easy for some the idea of like hey I
do a raid well you can go get a pinnacle
from strikes like
why is why are those that's still the
same that like but do we know the
requirement though do we really know
what that literally says though we these
are the weekly crucible strike and
gambit challenges whether it's do three
matches of gambit go do three strikes or
it's on the other side of its thorns in
this hour it's go do eight bounties one
of those two are the weekly challenges
and neither of those are what you would
call difficult especially in gambit is
to rip your way through three gambit
matches and you get a pinnacle piece of
gear okay so so you're against this it's
I'm not against the level race the 40
like the bigger jump better because as
you said makes the drops matter it makes
the powerful gear makes me play it for
longer as opposed to one day into a new
season I'm like hey like that bad last
season kind of sucked like this season
when you had like Indigo's like I didn't
feel it like 40 points between three
characters yeah you probably have to
play some powerful gear stuff between
all three especially if you want to mix
up gives you a little more you know more
to grind for for sure and yeah it's you
know some busy work but there's still
more to it but it's more the pinnacle
piece when you go okay so if this one's
40 and then you go Tim what if it goes
to a thousand 40 there was a bad like
the only good thing about the 10 to 10
before was the pinnacle mattered because
you literally were right there if you
were a pinnacle person and you started
your pinnacle grind you literally got a
leap up now even if you are right now
your gear levels 970 you're gonna get
blown away on the first day by people
doing strikes
so the carryover of season 2 season of
your pinnacle of the value of pinnacle
gear seems to have kind of lost its
luster again and this is where they
tried to give you something to aspire
towards hence our giant directors got
the discussion of aspiration why am I
gonna spire if now I know like we're
gonna be making bigger jumps and
powerful so that little tin gonna be
helpful for trials if you're gonna try
and be the elite of the elite and
probably gonna help you a little bit but
again where is the value of these
highest level activities when it comes
to the gear
okay it's we got and it's again it's
it's just it's a delicate line for the
middle walk because they tried the Tim's
and they're like well that seems a
little small okay then that got over and
now we did 40 last year it was like the
50 power level every time and we're kind
of back to a bigger jump which feels
good as you're playing for longer but
then it's the point of I can go do
strikes and be still at the same level
as somebody in about the same time now
probably who raids as much and which is
the heart of content falling through a
strike are doing a raid and you devalue
it's more devaluing the endgame content
not that I don't like them trying to
find a balance and again they're trying
to like walk both lines and it's next to
impossible no one's gonna be completely
happy I'm just basically coming from the
other side to you my question to you is
how do you resolve the issue din with
how would you handle the endgame
pinnacle + 2 + 2 for raids in trials and
plus ones for everything right there
that would be perpetually be good cuz
the Plus Ones pretty you can make some
progress the twos yeah give you more
incentive to do the bigger stuff you'll
get there faster and I could almost see
like the pinnacles cuz it will get down
a little bit below they talk about the
quote power cap they want to incentivize
later I would honestly like to see the
pinnacles at like the powers are 40 the
pinnacles are 20 I'd like to see a
bigger range if they're easier right
okay so I just want to know what your
attorney know and I think what Bob said
I think what what he said is perfect
like make the raids give a bigger drop
make the the easier stuff that you can
literally just get turn the game on for
be a slower progression I'm with that
I'm wait and I think I read you I think
that at the other day they're still
trying to find their way with this I
think we're very close
I like the initial you know powergrind
jump that the bigger power level jump
now we just gotta again equate the
different activities with different
value levels and I'm with you on it as
what does he would go
mmm yeah I think they're aware of that
that you know people who are playing the
endgame raids and stuff right getting
similar rewards is not cool so reads
trials whenever you know those are the
endgame content they need to offer
better rewards and more experience
points though yeah you know you're
ensuring the trials playlist what I I've
heard other people say if you're in a
playlist there there should be some sort
of multiplier if you're gonna be in the
trials playlist and you've played 30
games in a row
there should be stat ways of stacking
your XP if you do a raid and that's why
I think they need to add replayability
to raids is that you stay in that group
and you load right back into that raid
okay you're gonna get double exp or some
something like that that'll reward
people for their time we already talked
about like a raid a rotating raid
playlist pinnacle playlist where so that
the other rates actually have value and
it's like hey okay this week is cronniss
our job yeah
I'm saying yo this weekend he's that'd
be cool this week a score if I get get
this is great content that this sitting
on they can get more engagement if you
give another reward source and there's
so many people that came in recently new
light players whatever that didn't play
that content old players who don't
really have a reason to play it if they
can meet in the middle all right I can
go back and do like you're sending a
playlist and play with people that
haven't done it it gives you no use your
reason to go back and play and gives new
players a reason the viola contents oh
great great idea what we got eat next
thing they do talk about kind of the
power cap we know so the artifact is
gonna be effective this coming weekend
for the 13th after that on Tuesday the
17th that patch should mhm
basically they hope to deploy again
remember of course you know they may be
working from home live late but they're
trying to get the certification done so
a week later ends up so the main reason
they were trying to I guess maybe walk
the other line is they want to get a cap
in there and wanted to I want to ask you
guys what you think the cap for trials
and iron banner and that's gonna either
include gear and artifact how big of a
how big do you think that cap could be
what would you like it to be what do you
think is reasonable for average or what
do you think you know to make like the
end game really matter where do you guys
think that cap should end if they
actually when they get to implementing
it
ah its power in PvP was always something
I've kind of gone back and forth of when
they first announced it I was all right
this is cool it gives people a reason to
play Eevee bring your Power into PvP and
show it off but then the more I thought
about it the more I'm like you know what
I don't like that advantage that power
has mm-hmm but at the same time I like
giving bringing your power you know
you're a powerful Guardian are you going
it so I would like if there is some sort
of just plus-one kind of thing all right
you're more powerful you have a sled
advantage not you know I come up to you
and I shotgun you in the face and you
have you know a quarter health the left
something something I'm sorry no I'm
playing aren't banner and there's guys
that are a thousand and I'm 980 I'm not
that far you know I'm still pretty
powerful and I come around you in the
shotgun and it doesn't you know because
you like all right that's kind of
annoying that goes against the normal
play style but at the same time I still
like the idea of power playing some sort
of impact maybe you know you can capture
a zone faster or something some small
advantages that you know are a reason to
grind your power but at the same time if
you're not able to grind so much power
you're not gonna go into something like
trials and write out well I'm just
getting steamrolled are people that have
stacked Downey's that are 10 15 20
levels above me so yeah it's a touchy
subject I don't really
I don't know how I feel about it because
the more I think about playing PvP it
should just be your skill against my
skill but at the same time I see what
they're trying to do with bringing this
idea of being this powerful Guardian and
especially with proving your worth how
worthy are you you have all this power
so yeah it'll be interesting especially
week one I think there's gonna be a lot
of angry people that are just getting
steamrolled by people that are very very
powerful so it'll be interesting but
yeah I've really say both bad I'm torn
I'm torn I'm this is coming from a
person who is historically the power
matters guy historically I like the idea
of the guys that put in the work in the
game you know be rewarded for that level
of investment in the game however you
know with the introduction of the
artifact right in these extra power
levels and stuff like that it's made me
question it now it's made me say like is
it really necessary see this is what I'm
Tony it's like yes the person should be
rewarded but the other part of me is
like but if that person is being
rewarded is only doing PvE stuff why
should that affect PvP stuff so that's
where it's this this weird thing you
know saying and it's tough man because
at any other aspect I struggle with is
that we need trials and iron banner it
needs to be something that separates it
from regular crucible right so it's all
these little mini battles internal
battles I'm having with myself as to
whether it should stay or whether it
should go and you know the old d1 didn't
have an artifact right the old it was
just you know you play it or whatever so
this is tough you don't saying this is
too I think a good the outlier will be
this weekend where it's not enabled
because the people who are going to
grind are going to grind and you go in
there and you know I may be talking all
this messing now but it made like like
Bobby said it may not feel nice but I
wrote down on somebody who's a thousand
something already and you know
that I'll shotgun him and he looks at me
laughs and smacks me in the face it's
tough man I don't know this is what it a
few times I don't know the correct
answer on it if they got rid of it I
feel weird but I would understand in a
way you know I'm saying so again we just
my whole thing is if it does go away
well actually is not because they're
saying that it they're gonna do this
whole power cap right yeah well just our
captain they said your armor levels
gonna matter but the artifacts not right
so divided the only thing I can think of
it I think I talked about this last last
word was you kind of have to treat it
like a contest rule raid in the sense
that it's like okay after this amount of
power it don't matter how much of an
advantage you have what do you think you
should say that's that was my OD
question I know is you can you put a
number on that I think every week it
should change so let's say I mean I
can't really think of how quickly people
Bobby what the stock market just
increase it by five points or something
like that or me peep to make people
grind power so you know we - it's 990
and if you're not you know that's I
don't know just it's tricky the
trickiest hour because
I know it's easy the easy solution is
just say alright power doesn't matter
and then I want that though I don't
necessarily want that all the way yeah
most people would be fine with it
because like I said it's PvP power
shouldn't matter but at the same time I
think it brings in this element of you
know you grinded you deserve to be more
powerful right should be so mine I don't
i so so 960s the entry point right now
sixties where we jump in you're allowed
to do trial we're gonna be like nine
ninety come Friday you know that flasher
you know you already know they you know
I'm trying to think what's the good
contest rule so I mean a girl line out
there that I'm sure it was out there
throw years unless I had wondered about
this to you because I'm in the same boat
as you guys when it comes to if I
shoulder charge somebody or if I
handheld supernova somebody I want that
to do what I always feel like it should
do I want the mechanic to work the same
but as you said it's also like if it is
always that the why isn't it just quick
play so some way to set it apart it's
the stupid line in theory I think a safe
power cap and again it's all in how
quick you could get there would be
twenty you could have the pinnacles meet
ten some people are gonna get those
faster who raid or do trials right but
if you do the season pass and you get
your rank pretty high and you are a
bounty grinder and you also get up to
that point with less pinnacles and then
after twenty as you're saying contest in
no higher than twenty over power like
this season ten twenty four example
table Tony would be your total power
level cap that can give you any type of
benefit anything beyond that nada so you
can either get your see just one hard
cap that once you reach level power line
eighty nine ninety that's it you go
above it doesn't matter anymore
yep yeah so this season if we're going I
wasn't for powerful thousand ten for
pentonville's say you raid a crap-ton
you do every dungeon everything you can
for pinnacles you're like rocking
through you're like ah ten oh five and
then the next week you do it again
you're ten ten and you've also been
playing a lot your season passes got you
plus ten that's all you're ever gonna
get now you could get gear you can get
your artifact to like plus thirty if you
lose your mind right it's not gonna
matter so after like ten and ten and
that variation gives you some pinnacles
as the pinnacles are gonna get easier
right that ten levels is it that hard
and then your artifact so again as the
pinnacles get easier that number may
change the way it feels now twenty isn't
gonna put you completely out of reach
but it's also gonna give you some at
reason to aspire towards the harder
stuff that was my theory I feel like we
go yeah are you going
you know because again it still
incentivizes that grind to one it gets
stronger but again I like the mentality
of you know I got a play to get strong
gonna get into trials I want to be at
optimum levels who doozy I do like that
aspect you know I'm saying so again not
long as they have that you know that cat
and then cuz again you don't want it to
be you don't want it to degenerate into
okay
all I'm gonna do is just grind grind
grind grind grind and it's just mythical
number and this person is just
completely god stomping everyone because
he's got it's got to be a cut-off at
some point I'm saying so yeah I would
you I think that's for you yeah so we'll
see how it all goes again the pinnacles
and again if they did something like hey
pinnacles could get could get a little
higher cuz they're easier next season
maybe that number adjust but somewhere
in there as you said like a contest hard
stop of after this I don't care how you
get there between artifact or here
doesn't matter
and that's that gives everybody at a
point even later in the season it can't
be infinite that's the point as the cap
does have to be there at some point
exactly I'm with it they do have a tease
of just kind of a ever verse update they
didn't say there's gonna be bring about
kind of a daily rotating module one
they're getting rid of the purchasable
bright engrams and I think that's mostly
just a loop box lawsuits do you cut like
laws that are gonna be coming they're
just getting ahead of that the daily
rotating bright engrams honestly just
for old stuff and it just can't be like
a this old thing we found in the back
closet it's on sale do you want it yes I
mean I still need my spare rations
ornament so I every week I go looking
for and they haven't put it in there so
I need my spare rations ornament and
then this is when we come up to the
picture Wow so okay first I think half
the people myself included who looked at
this picture had the classes wrong I'm
you guys look I didn't told this morning
yeah so looking in the middle you're
like okay big fluffy Arctic Russian keep
me warm robe ornate warlock looks fired
yeah nailed that would you got a target
on your stomach but I guess that's just
what I'm gonna shoot you but all the one
over to the right looks like he's gay
you know he's been working out his arms
he's got that stout chest he's got like
that he's got the leather jacket on
looking pretty good and then I look to
the left and I was like who's shafted
who shopped in goodwill and pull without
their parents 80's clothes and then they
found and this is like their Guardian
level one mask look and it's like doing
this to us you figure out later on
you've got like a half a trash bag for a
Titan towel because you see it's
actually a hunter with a longer cloak
even though it's not over his head
because the symbols are on the pieces
and I'm like wait what just listened now
I know it's a female model so it's not
gonna have a stocking of his shoulders
even if that was a dude what happened to
our armor on this pic this is the this
is sad it's so sad like I hate to hate
on people for their
creativity but this is just I mean I
felt like I was it if I was at Bungie
and there was some meeting really all
right here's the new everywhere armor
here's the Warlock cool here's the
hunter oh wow that looks really cool for
a hunter and here's a Titan how did
everyone not in that room be like wait
what is the Titan it's like redo it go
back sit down do it again
here's the funny point if you look at
the image from the wall actor the hunted
to the right he don't even be a guy's
guardian yeah he's like the last kid
picked in fireteam class or something
he's like oh it's like we're down to two
people do you want the girl do you want
that weird guy over there I'll take the
girl that dudes weird and that's what we
are we ate so many crayons and we and we
got drunk in our closet or something I
don't know man he's got like boots with
like zippers I don't know what happened
to him so what does shader it's like
green jacket with like a deep neck but a
zip-up shirt that's bright or the mark
looks like half a jacket ripped in half
he went to Goodwill and made up an
outfit cuz he's got like dress boots
they look like green boots like rubber
rain boots like galoshes or whatever
they're called it looks that that helmet
literally looks like it's got a string a
rubber band behind it holding the mask
on dude it looks like this is like
garden this is like kindergartens like
cardboard and cut out mass the other to
man it's just like I'm looking I'm not
blocking out the Titan and I'm looking
at the hunter in the world and then
you're like Oh what like I said it looks
like that was the original design for
the warlock or something and they're
like does we don't really like that try
something in and then they did it design
this dope warlock armor and then oh crap
he's got a Titan how about this oh yeah
sure make that into a mark though it's
fully you sit above because because
thematically
stylistically usually the Titans are
always in the middle in the wall I can
hunters are on the side so that's what
he made us confuse you'll say it's just
that that's awful I just got like the
armor the hunters arms that are horrid
jacked fire why why do we have just
sleeves like in the biggest biggest L is
the ghosts the warlock has the almighty
ghost the Hunter has the ghost covered
in snakes and the Titan you has a damn
lunchbox like yeah it's bad listen I
will never besmirch just the first I've
never besmirched a great artist at but
but someone should aside and said this
is not a go but it tight this is not a
go you you're good at your job but you
did this one shows me more then you
scroll the finishers are below that so
if you guys aren't seeing what I'm
talking about it's just this weekend
Bungie so you've got the hunter finisher
the art staff uppercut yep looks
freaking awesome and then I scrolled
down I'm like the Titan he's doing kind
of like a clap and then I could look at
the Warlock I'm like if you line up
those animation timings and I did it on
Street yeah they're almost the same
yeah the Morlocks just crouched more and
yeah goes back more where the Titans
like oh I have power oh there you go
here I guess almost thrown at you this
was actually on vacation and somebody
was like I'm gonna just like move a
couple things we'll get it out there
somebody from the wall I see you did
yeah dirty I'm just like really getting
the finishers now the second I could see
that like finish your button pop so yeah
that was so cool that they added that at
first was like whatever barely use it
now I use it all the time the second I
see like a major with that little yellow
yeah save your ammo man got you
I used strategically for special ammo oh
I've got izanagi
shots for days yeah oh yeah that's my
flow rate it looks cool but it just
doesn't fit like they could have just
made it maybe he gets it in his fist and
he pounds the ground like actually what
Schott said that's exactly what my chat
said last night when I showed him there
like why not do a fish slam like it's
art that is what the is known for the
fist slam the fist of havoc yeah any of
those just go just punch down at the
ground and just like send a shock wave
out or something like that mean I don't
know this is yeah this one's always
weird so this I can't look at that
anymore so we got to move on yeah let's
move on that's arguably the worst what
makes it so much worse that the other
two are so good oh there's some dope I'm
not even a big ever verse Armour fan
usually but this looks dope
gonna settle it tight the literally
somebody was like the warlock was like
the suave dude the hunters the like jock
and then the the Titan for some reason
is the kid and chess club like yes
another tab and I kept going to it a
little while thank you guys for sticking
with us but we are on the last little
piece here we have some exotic changes
and a little bit else so for the final
preview we've got exotic changes coming
uh hunters we can all just kind of
comment and see as we go and then we'll
take our respective classes Sasson
scallop the invisibility healing effects
now trigger on power melee and finishers
and it's on melee not kill it says so
kind of different depending on how that
goes
duration of the invisibility increased
depending and they have a couple of
these that are based on the tier of the
enemy so like red orange yellow like
majors is gonna make things last longer
which is kind of cool
that's kind of you kind of cool the
assassin scale getting a little tweak
the Frosty's changed the ability
regeneration so that no longer stacks
multiplicatively with other class
ability energy generating perks I think
just bouncing that one kept reaching
this one sounds lethal all smoke bombs
deal 150% damage while wearing this
exotic like that's gonna kill you dude
that's good that's real good that's good
Khepri got a lot of functionality down
with that orpheus rigged the maximum
amount of super you can gain from a
single use of shadow shot is 50%
they're putting a hard and fast line of
what you can get from that thing
yeah the spire of good that's good it's
about time cuz it became that thing
where you're like you have to use this
so I get super so it's good that they're
changing that on yep
young I'm Cara spying the explosion
radius by 14% so just a little little
buff to tripmines there not a shabby mmm
alright so Bob your Titan man I know I'm
too but I'm talking here so I'm gonna
bounce these off of you and then warlock
I go to you can you know first one ashen
waiting killing an enemy with a fusion
grenade while wearing this exotic now
refunds grenade energy the amount of
grenade energy refriended based on the
tier of enemy killed dots that's gonna
work well with what's that thing called
that grenade launcher that we got this
season martyrs retribution yeah you know
life you can really spec yourself to be
a big time they really like grenades
I've realized yes no word late grenade
launchers got buff we got tackle assured
a launcher it's uh they're giving you a
new way to play so cool I like that any
any exotic that has an in-game direct
benefit element I'm always down for us
though no that sounds good to me
um and say us Ward's the slide now look
no longer allows clip damage or chip
damage through it which yeah those are
honestly like for a montage real have
never seen those as being anything that
i use doom fang paul drewes a still
makes the bug we're doing fake pauldrons
sometimes grant super dodgy from melee
kills while in your super that's just a
fixed now this was fine I don't remember
why I was using dude marchers what was a
running fast for I was doing something
and I was farming whatever I needed to
go quickly for through stuff I think it
could have been just like lost sector
grind or something and I was running up
in May laying things with the static
charge and I was actually like killing
enemies and it might have just been
melee kills that I needed and now like
12 meters goes to 20 meters for that
static discharge that's a long ways like
that's nice that's like a 100 battle
making offensive PvP as well yeah that's
a viable thing to wear in PvP and I wear
them sometimes so actually I'm looking
at my my inventory right now and I have
them on because I was trying some
different stuff after trials so row
battle oh I might throw that on
that's that'll be interesting to play
around with mm-hm
another one for a shoulder Chargers the
mark 44 state decides reduced
the lay of the start of sprinting until
the overshield becomes comes in 2.5
seconds down from 1 to 1.5 seconds
mmm nice little buff to that shoulder
charge huh yeah yeah I'm down with that
you know those warlocks got extended
melee which I already thought was too
much so now they're getting even lower
you bop dude I get hit by warlocks out
of nowhere and it's just like boom how
you hit me so that's gonna be even
longer oh I don't use my shoulder charge
hammer strike primarily to damage people
I use it for movement especially in PvP
I like having that why it's easy to do
with the game yes continue yeah but you
need that see I'm able I've gotten real
good at using that to like blast around
turn around and hit someone so get
around a lot but when I when I need to
use it to blast someone it's nice so
I'll take it
Hey in fairness in fairness this next
one you should be happy about even ah
here we go
I've seen I've been facing this thing as
I tighten even more likes funny is I
never used one I met cuz I just didn't I
was a huge cyntha SEPs I used to the set
yeah that's the only exotic that when
you why did you use I'm curious because
I you sit the steps all the time and
because I I was a big like shotgun guy
for a while where I was running around
it was like yeah whatever I don't need
it I put it on this week something
alright I'm sniping now getting ready
for trials this would be good and then
all of a sudden they do this this big
time nerf here I'll let you yeah I'm
happy about it cuz honestly it's just
been it's out of line for a while and if
you're finally doing the right thing so
the target marking from this exotic has
been a place to target highlighting
eliminating the ability to see through
walls and no wall habits it right there
and it's all hack setup to things so
they're really trying to get away yeah
yeah
no longer provides a damage bonus when
defeating your marked target also good
restoring the previous over shield
granted by defeating your mark target
which now has a duration of six seconds
stead of eight so you get the over
shield it's shorter no wall hacks and no
damage bonus lake this is this is down a
lot this is majorly this feels right
this feels not okay
probably still gonna use it in trials
just for that overshield because it's
nice
sniping you know if I get body shot I
can come back at them take them out get
that over show whatever but ya know it
was uh I think that this has been a bane
of the PvP community for a long time and
I know a lot of people are gonna be very
happy with this like I said I didn't
really use it that much even as a fight
in Maine I would sure see a lot and get
very frustrated when I was going up
against it so good I'm glad you know
they didn't touch my set the set so I'm
happy with you all right yeah absolutely
absolutely long overdue yeah and then
the new one the severance enclosure the
explosion now triggers on our Howard
melee both against combatants and
guardians and finishers radius and
damage of the explosion created based on
the tier of the enemy this is like good
thing they're bringing in the tier of
the enemy change yeah it's work it's
kind of get a cool just see how it
actually pays off like yeah I think they
want you to use your abilities in
different situations so this gives you a
reason I'm just wondering like if I
actually go finish off and punch a giant
like ogre boss is it gonna like blow the
whole room up like I need to know if
that's actually gonna be worth the risk
because if I go punch a boss and I kill
I'm like not gonna matter well yeah
we'll see warlock all right sir kognito
you're up one of these is actually being
sold today oh yeah apotheosis veil yeah
this exotic is now guaranteed to drop
with a minimum of plus sixteen to
intellect okay yeah that's not every job
every exotic should have the cassette
something yeah they all should be yeah
they should all have that makes sense
with synergy yeah what reduce the damage
reduction granted by this exotic to 20%
down from 40% are you happy now is this
is this to your liking hair between the
the handheld supernova and this it
should bring it a little more in line
you're still gonna be able to kill me
farther than my shoulder charge can but
mmm-hmm it's gonna be hopefully actually
didn't they say the comb got tired and
like you gotta aim it now
okay the cone got tighter but you're
actually probably gonna hit more like
you're gonna be more act if you do hit
one person though you'll definitely kill
him yeah yeah yeah you got you gotta aim
it and then remember to charge now last
less so you can't just walk around it
back
yep don't wanna so this is this is fair
I mean at the end of the day 40% which I
did not know it was even that I was like
yeah damage traductor a huge dick sound
this one's for me they they Bugsy got
expose big damn it same green alchemy so
everybody has received a complete
redesign its new perk blood magic allows
the where to pause the countdown timer
of any riff they're standing in by
getting weapon kills extending the rifts
duration now full disclosure are you
Walters my secret this was my secret
weapons go to you I had a build that was
gonna get me rips so that my team could
stay at risk and see where the enemies
at this was by trials see I was hoping
they didn't see me in the corner using
this and they busted me god dammit this
was my joy here I go for it so but look
it's fear you cannot have more hacking
stuff in trials this is the utmost
competitive activity no advantages no
cheating
so if what I'm asking in it sanguine
gotta get it so I be Alyssa and here's
my other point this is for e now what I
like about this whole thing you see what
they did they reworked in exile or love
but check this out because I know we've
had this discussion about exotics and
how you know you can't have when it
comes to weapons you can't have oh you
know snipers in the same prey because
you know it's it's the same archetype
you're doing the same thing you're
making a new exotic bin so why not make
a new exotic and leave the old one in
the past how about let's not touch what
we have let's just rework it how about
you know where's the sexual nature of
earning this new thing that functions in
a completely different way why is it
even still called the same thing but
also usually you'd rather them get rid
of sangrita guy yes you're gonna sing
quitting and bring in a new one
oh I like her but she's doing shout out
to Bungie on this reworking existing
excise give me the new functionality not
destroying them not getting rid of them
giving them function that that's all it
looks like it could be done but anyway I
shall continue oh well you don't
actually like this perk maybe I'll go
try it out it's a great TV it's a great
PvE / that's gonna feel very new Bobbi's
so cool you could sit there and like an
empowering your for a long time this is
bursts of people that are doing solo
stuff this is they're gonna be right
this is gonna be a very powerful exactly
so again it's that stop segue
now here's the one that's very
interesting Athenian aspects now
increases the lunge range of all Bayley
attack even if the ability is odd cooled
down now let me buff you are too much
further now you're gonna push even
farther this is my go-to for what I
think warlocks I feel is the deal y'all
here's the deal I know y'all don't like
this I know the disgust is gonna be
there but here's why I do like it's a
fair bet for me but here's the thing
remember when they made the nerf to Luna
fashion alright remember you in a
faction was to go to everybody reload
right yep so all I'm saying is okay a
fit Ian had the same function now they
lived in the same space there's really
because now you're nerfect this and all
just doing is reloading a fitting didn't
have any place so giving it something
else with it with the lunge range now
yes
is it a little guy go Freddy there's a
little beasty
that I don't have a melee power and I'm
still getting there but that's a little
beasty I go a lot like I ain't gonna be
mad that they do hey guys I'm all up but
it it's a little beasty that I don't
even have to have a melee charge and my
melee but I will say this it definitely
gives a feed Ian
new specific role that's all I'm saying
now whether you agree with that role as
a whole different argument and I could
hear you on that but I do like that
Ophidian now is different from Luna
faction just making things reload faster
that's all I can say all right here
y'all complain complain hear this I'm
just gonna have to see how it goes or
you punch further than all of us and now
you're gonna definitely be able to get
the leap on those punching battles so
literally stated if you get it at range
you are going to win because you're able
to start it first I'm gonna with AC at
the same time and at the same time yes
I'm faster but I'm gonna whiff while you
can hit me and then guess what
why yeah that Lou I just said distance
yes oh yeah listen we need something man
ya know if they're doing this to maybe
try and make people stay farther apart
not be running around shock slide
shotgunning and mailing because I'm
trying to up that's why I looked up I'm
looking at dim right now my warlock is
currently wearing a fitting a sex
because that's what I wear I try and
keep all my builds the same on like my
hunter I stop e-cell I like the movement
speed my lock has a favorite aspects my
Titan has synthesis I like things that
are constantly giving me buffs so yes
like but what wait the fitti it is just
moved up oh yeah
and specially for trials because it's D
remember it gives you that snapshot kind
of you know if a PvP that's critical
relook like a feeding is because going
to be top-tier for trial general shut up
the smell go he's gonna chat you he was
with me to interviewed you oughta
impacts that easy to chat you say hey
Bobby it's good or styled opt it's good
on that put on yeah man I mean Ophidian
just went up the rankings yah this is
gonna be serious for PvP I'm with you
Bobby yeah I might have to dust it off
and bring it back out man yeah I have to
bring it out so yeah so then we got last
at least it's now we have very DS brow
the buff I've never used this exotics
crazy the buff provided by this exotic
now increases your grenade damage by 10%
per stack the buff to allies grenade
recharge rate now kicks in when you
cashed your name this exotic now
provides a buff text notification
indicating how many allies are currently
benefiting from your increased grenade
charge what do you think about verities
brow Bobby what you thinking I mean this
is one of those seems like situational
no specific kind of exotics here
no no I like it yeah it's giving you
know anything that gives more
versatility something here I mean yes
another thing that I didn't know ever
use this bro yeah I look it up I'm like
yeah I don't think I ever use this but
uh okay interesting
man-wolf dust it off right let's give
you a night let's see what it do that's
what's cool is when they retool or you
know really change the perks is answer
sorry how can I Bobby could you repeat
that sentence that was a really
informative centenary tourmaline it was
it was glorious which is I just would
love to you to release yeah all right
you I like change but uh you didn't even
know the thing existed so if they
literally like we're like hey here's
this new exotic that does these things
it wouldn't be any different
how about giving value to stuff that's
garbage that we don't use and reworking
it so that it's sexy and attractive
again I like this I think you do realize
my argument was never over armor by the
way
what I'm applying it to weapons Oh I
know you only can't change the
functionality of a weapon without
completely remaking it you can rework
certain like you can you can remake
sanguine alchemy to function completely
differently whisper the worm is still
gonna feel like whisper of the worm it
may be a buff Turner but they've changed
the functionality on the nail perk
they've done this stuff before yeah it's
certainly where when you think about
like what they're doing as far as
changing the way something works like oh
now we put the switch in it does this
but hashtags save the exotics Italy
definitely say that so the main reason
this argument is here is over the whole
retiring of legendary weapons we've got
we win and added over two weeks and then
last week I was literally asking him and
I had a very simple question and it took
me about 15 minutes to get an answer but
I did finally get one and we just agree
to disagree so I just kind of want to
see your nuttin take for example dusty -
we don't know how long it's gonna last
you know he wouldn't answer the question
because he kept saying destiny 3 might
be coming next year it might be coming
the year after that we don't know at
this point so say the game doesn't
personally don't I don't think they're
gonna do it I think they're gonna try
and follow the World of Warcraft thing
where they just constantly release
expansions but that's new information on
this that's just my quick thought about
it but yes no one
so anyway theoretically all all I was
trying to get as a theoretical answer
whether destiny 3 literally comes out in
September this wasn't that wasn't the
point of the question you done no you're
not you're dancing like ask was
literally to say whisper the worm was a
year one exotic if destiny to continued
on for say like hey we're in destiny to
year six should you be able to infuse
even like legendaries we know they're
gonna be working on like sunsetting
after a certain amount of time yep
should I be able to take whisper the
worm into the ear 6 raid or is there a
point where exotics should be sunset as
well
so my general this is the competition
breeds better results so I would love
for them to be like alright whisper the
worm is Opie it's great they nerfed it
that was their reaction to it obviously
I would wish they would just introduce
new weapons introducing exotics problem
with that is then everything that's
already at the bottom is even farther at
the bottom so when they nerf exotics and
they do this and that it reshuffles the
tearless mm-hmm I don't I the problem is
yes me I would I wish they wouldn't I
would like to especially if you have a
gun like whisper that that was one of
the greatest missions quest I ever go oh
that was chests a twitch ass dude that
was louder I will never forget I will
never forget getting that running other
people through it that was so sick why
do I want to be able to use that forever
yeah I would love to be able to use that
forever but at the same time any idea
what that does to me on audio seriously
quit it but at the same time I
understand why they do it because you
know they want they they need to change
things up you know if everyone was still
running whisper that would be stale so
as hard it is for me to say it because
trust me I would love to still be rock
and whisper and every other gun that was
okay I think it it they have to do
nerves I just it just sucks when it's
completely with the structure that's not
nerves here no question is Westray he is
saying he wants it just how they doing
legendaries right they're doing after
nine to 12 months yeah they're doing a
retirement with it no longer be in few
what he wants is with a key was said to
apply to exotics as well
my heart says no I wish my heart says no
but my head is like but my brain is like
yeah you know it that is the way to make
things change but I would rather then
introduce new stuff that you want to use
that's like oh wow I have this great gun
but here's this new great gun so I guess
when it comes to the argument that you
guys are talking about yes yes kinda in
the middle on it okay you're in the
middle of my space but you do want it to
stay you would like whispered not to go
away I don't want to lose Thor him I
don't want to lose thorne I love
throwing it's my favorite gun in mine it
was all of a sudden like okay you saw
anymore I find a new guard but the same
time I'd be like in this sucks like when
we couldn't use this pretty more right
that's not good
I hear you say my you know shout out to
cook I'll say it he's a three-hour
podcast we're not gonna do it I'm gonna
be I'm gonna be nice I'll be nine now
here's here's the dick and I just want
to say this last point cuz I hear where
you come from and what he is saying for
the longevity of the game yeah I hate
his point he doesn't think I agree with
him for much from a power creep
standpoint from you know saturation hue
saturation standpoint right all I was
saying was exactly to represented a
small percentage I'm with a more
legendaries right now he asked a hard
and fast question which was how long
Cognito do we still be running these old
exotics in two years seven and six and I
hear his point and my counter to that
why I struggled to give him a year was I
said he said I said dig dig dig round
three was that I said they have to give
us a new game
at that point right so now we've got
some new information that I'd like to
bring to the last learn shout out to my
man unknown player who just made a great
video and guess what d3 is in
development still it is still happening
it was started around forsaken and guess
what this small little team that is
working on current d2 projects right the
majority of this studio because everyone
acts like they can they just can't do it
it's not enough reason guess what the
majority of the studio is doing they are
working on d3 which is to my point and
then there's this other game called
matter that they're working at there's
another team or net so that's the Bungie
is huge who's currently working right
now is the small B team on what we're
getting now to ease point right now
they're not ready to do d3 right but to
my point it's not gonna be five six
years we're gonna stuck stick with this
and that we have to make this tough
decision to get rid of whisper that's
what I'm saying the new game is going to
come to accommodate what I'm talked
about that's all I have to say I'm done
are you yeah I think this is where you
probably have to look at something like
other games and how does something like
World of Warcraft do this because I
played it back in the day but I haven't
played wow and forever right so I don't
know do that can you still use weapons
from the first couple years no not right
every every so mansion when you get like
go 60 to 70 or 110 to 120 as soon as
you're like 112 on your way to 120 the
110 stuff that was epic raid took you
days and days to grind for it's gone so
I mean that's kind of the idea of and
yes believe me it's like of all people
in this podcast whisper has a special
place for me it is my biggest video I've
ever had and may ever will I was like so
believe me I love the quest I love
taking people through that people ask me
it's like and I can still do those jumps
it's like it's engrained in my head but
it's also to the point of like that
freshness to where and again I did state
this whole thing when I was trying to
get you answering I was like we're
probably expecting d2 yes I did I said
it how I don't know how many
times you betrayed the exotics you
betrayed us
you sold out your greatest memory your
biggest video you say I could go we
could go to shut this sound because I
said theoretically if in six years and
this is just a concept that we were
trying to get out of retiring things if
it if a game did last that long if they
take d3 Sadie I know that's the whole
point of a theoretical as if come on I'm
not gonna cut that [ __ ] but I'm really
good and on the board of it mmm-hmm if
they're just happen if okay what if d3
is finally bungees thing and they make
last that long what if the do you want
everything in there to last for six
seven years in d3 asking me I know your
answer say well I know yours
yeah we've been down this before it took
me a while I got an answer so you get
something in d3 it is a new game there's
something cool yeah you get you know
thorn 2.0 whatever gun you love d3 is
that thing they do attach to they build
out their studio they're sticking with
it for a while it's got the
infrastructure it's got the new engine
it is that thing that can last for five
six years how long I mean is it the
point where I know exotics are cool do
you ever see a point in a game like that
where if they're sunsetting legendaries
you sunset in exotic with it same
principle I think it's inevitable
because like we said it does make you
change everything up when you can't use
the most opie weapon anymore um I just
as long as they don't delete guns from
the game which I know isn't what they're
gonna do you know as long as you're not
deleting weapons that's okay um yeah I
don't know it's hard how do you put a
number on something theoretical but if
you could use a gun for use a gun let's
say for a year at minimum I think that's
good I know that's you know that not was
at nine fifty months for legendaries is
kind of what they're thinking you know
you have a year with a weapon that
sounds like a good amount of time but I
don't know it's it's tricky man it's
it's hard because this game is a lute
bass game you wanna you know you work
hard to get the great loot you work hard
to get the gravy you want
you'll find somebody on my side of this
argument it's fine it's like I want to
agree with God but at the same time I I
know you're saying you need to change
things up and if you're not able to
constantly bring in the next Opie weapon
and then that you know you're just
shifting to a new meta and you're
shifting the T around you got it you got
to make changes so mmm it's hard for me
to say agree with that but I think for
the longevity of a game and to keep that
constant change and not running the same
motor because yeah it is kind of
annoying when you go to do something and
it's like oh do you have 1k voices now I
don't have that you know what I mean
like I I never got that gun I haven't
got 1k I would love to have it or you
know someone new that doesn't have
whisper it's Bobby yeah with that same
vein right you just made a good point
you don't have one cake you never got it
never got it so with the new cadence
that uh
pontus is talking about you know in a
year or two years or whatever that is
four years you'd I'm saying 1k goes away
yeah but you never got it yeah it would
be cool so what I'm thinking is so let's
say they sunset items and it's like all
right you can no longer infuse up this
power right but there should be some
like old-school activities where you go
in and say you know what I'm gonna run
whisper in this which is dead oh yeah
throwback strike or talk about whatever
memory strike so as long as you can
still use things you love like maybe
down at the end game I'm fine with it
yeah it's it's a tricky thing man you
don't want to take away people's
people's gifts and what they worked hard
for so yeah I feel listened I think
we're actually all in the same point
yeah I just think that you know the his
theoretical is not realistic because
okay Mario's not gonna happen okay your
reticle for d3 is actually a better
argument now cuz you say if d3 is coming
then the theory if that's the one they
build for the longer term that's where
it actually could be a fake but but
here's the thing my counterpoint again
is just the nature of tech it's the Nate
listen the way things are right now
right there's always gonna be
it's like a gas tank there's always
gonna be that point when you're gonna
get to capacity right so at some point
what they're doing now is they say hey
we got to remove activities we gotta
remove activities because we're getting
to that threshold even the next
generation there will be another
threshold we talked about 4k assets we
talked about all these new rate racing
all that's new functionality at some
point there's a limit to the structure
of the world any generation so they're
always going to be a curve that's why
new games exist all I'm trying to say is
with d3 whether it be four to five years
as opposed to two to three years it's
gonna happen again
that's all I'm saying right now we're
currently doing maintenance we're doing
band-aid stuff because they're not ready
to do d3 right right now but in a year
or two years it's happening all I said
is if you take my exotics power point if
you take the exotics away all I'm saying
is then give me a new game with
dedicated servers or new functionality
and I'm cool with it you know you'll
have to blow up the tower every time
that's literally all it's just the
exotic yeah but we're just give me new
really good exotics I mean they do that
I remember if you could look back every
season I have a lota I remember I was
rocking ace it was a positive outlook
that fusion rifle me that's the name of
it that thing was great and then I had
hammerhead like that was my loadout for
a whole season and then another season
comes I change it up a bit but I always
have that gun like when it comes to PvP
see that's where like maybe don't sunset
guns in PvP I don't know I don't want to
start down there well we'll leave it
alone cuz we will go but again this is a
good it's good discussion yeah yeah we
he's always had this you know it's it's
very it's a very cool thing to think
about it and everybody's excited to see
you know what's gonna happen when we do
get actual d3 and stuff like that so
legendary investment baby we got we got
some stuff going on legendary engrams
increase the number of armor sets
available from world drops from up to 11
instead of 3 that is an insane jump but
also means your legendary loop pool just
got very armor heavy by the way you're
gonna have a much harder time getting
the weapon you want in the role you want
and almost would like if there's a point
where whether it be Rahul had like an
option if you're gonna go by the
legendary engrams
do you want armed ready weapons like
there's got to be a point where you can
train still somewhat steer towards
weapons especially if you were buying
buying in grams for shards like you can
buy from him like 25 people will dump
10,000 shards trying to get a roll on
something yeah and if half of that's I
did it I did it to try and get a last
hope and whatnot yep
yeah I saw stereo so scary lose his mind
when he got his perfect last hope on
Twitter I don't know if you saw that it
I got it from a world drop from the
obelisk yeah that's what he did he was
turning into just eat
he had fractal and gave up in the tower
for the bend he's just turning in an
obelisk he got a last hope multi kill
clip feeding frenzy and he just lost his
mind that's what I got I got a multi
feeding high Cal reload mass or just
rate I know I I never use solder I don't
like sidearms they just don't feel like
the kind of weapon I want to use in this
game but yeah oh well I'd use it I'm
like ooh things nice good it's nice
actually use the side home yet and peeps
it's the buff so I got a try I got a do
it said it will include faction rally
armor so you can go get your dead orbit
and new monarchy we send in the
frenemies monarchy yeah I got seen eyes
said sets that were previously
unavailable or extremely difficult will
be available world stats
here's the big one armor says prime
engrams will now more reliably drop
armor with higher overall stats and
spiky err distributions exotics armor
will now more reliably have higher
overall stat rules legendary armor now
has an improved chance of receiving
higher stat rules though low rules will
still be present thank you just give us
a shot cuz I can't tell you how many
things I've broken down from the tower
like the obelisk
oh my god the number of like the number
pieces of armor when I turned into stuff
that the obelisk is just like 48 47 49
50 51 48 billion elite elite I don't
care about it but Slyke you give me a
hope right now it's so little it's not
even a hope that's like even like prime
engrams I would say once you were trying
to add a cap and you're getting the same
yeah it's like the excitement of getting
that prime goes away so if you're giving
us better stats at least you know you
take a second look at it the key point
is spiky or distribution I like a lot if
you
those bills like you know saying yes
something like all 20 in in recovery or
20 in you know says something that
you're building towards and you get that
in that category now you added
excitement I thought this whole section
was for he I like it a listen to what it
like doesn't is that what you go into
[Music]
bit of heresy you finished that one you
get a guaranteed piece of armor that's
masterwork its master worked with the
+12 and you're looking at like 62 you're
like dude this like is awful like so
yeah yeah it gives you the 10 energy but
no so again hopefully all that stuff is
gonna be coming to be better and seems
like that actually should be coming with
the launch of the season not that midway
point so just that rules should
generally be better
they're also up a on my stab to and I
cannot wait for that yeah I heard in
someone else's stream someone had a
really good idea for the factions so if
you want to get a specific factions like
was it diet bonus is that the really
good hand cannon yeah so you go to that
dead orbit and you go not donate but you
go handed in rewards there so you only
get the armor you know every just so you
know maybe faction Ellie's still aren't
a thing but you can spend in rewards to
this faction and you'll get that
specifically because I all I care about
is through party key and I'm like
they're like I like the fact that is
introduced in the loop pool but it's
gonna be so randomized yeah and I'm
saying if you just want something
specific so yeah it would be cool that
if they still had the NPC's you can go
to them and you know yeah I agree I know
it's just hard the records there's no
tokens no more but yeah if it was some
way to do that that'd be cool
mm-hmm yeah yeah just the quest screens
getting updated so things are gonna kind
of be in their own little buckets I'm
very curious to see what that looks like
because I feel like I mean they made
progress but definitely wasn't it's
still just like whole bunch of quests
and weird order and bounties that are
not organized and hoping this gets a
little a little bit of just a burst when
they first change it I was a mess but
it's gotten better yeah shout out to you
I getting some some love mm-hmm
we got the performance thing right yeah
so there's a couple little I mean those
are basically performance issues for
like you I stuttering frame rate in
gambit gambit prime frame rate issues in
multiple places like sanctified mind pit
of heresy dungeon a big stutter on high
frames and PC just general fixes for
stuff and then outside of that they just
kind of cover the date and time all this
stuff so on Tuesday they're gonna take
things down now just keep in mind
depending on if you guys are affected by
daylight savings time that is this
weekend on Sunday so to spring forward
those yeah team times are gonna change
so now daily reset is gonna be at 10:00
a.m. Pacific instead of 9:00 a.m.
Pacific so for me it's noon
so everything's pushed back about an
hour that's pretty standard for spring
but you will be kicked out about an hour
before for them to take it down and get
the patch out there and roll out the
update stone if you aren't home and you
want to make sure you'd log in when you
get home make sure your Playstations on
so it uploads make sure your steam is
open and like auto-updating make sure
things are gonna do its updates so it
you can actually get home and login so
you're not waiting for stuff especially
PlayStation you guys copy-pasting twice
that just takes a little extra long well
that's about it I mean there's a couple
of the videos as always but next week it
begins Ben it's all life is real I'm
ready man yeah for me it's just all
about now you know I've seen a chance to
play much this week come back from pax
but you know for me it's definitely
about getting in that crucible starting
to figure out loadout starting in you
know I know Bobby you talked about you
was doing there and I got to get going
because I got to see what works what's
effective I know things are gonna get
buff
but I gotta kind of get in my pocket
cause I'm a sweat yeah sweat a little
bit it's ready I'm ready to get sweaty
at the end of the day you know is it
might you know oh I'm going like house
you know week one no but most likely not
but you know it's more about just
getting again if those boundaries are
there which I'm hoping you know I'm
saying getting in that cadence getting
and everything like Friday could not
come your eighty faster I just literally
my whole goal is hopefully orangey
blesses me and I get that wall I could
move it wolf help me out I'm good to
come you guys I just need something from
that set so that I know that baby's back
oh I'm hiding man child's back then we
got some good people content I'm gonna
be grinding as soon as that reset starts
you know you guys doing the bounty thing
you guys all get prepped moles talking
up no I usually do if there's some
reason I just haven't been drawn to it I
just been focused on just getting ready
for PvP mm-hmm I'm just gonna grind hard
when the season drops and just try and
raise it as naturally as I can and yeah
I'm pretty good I think one of my
characters yeah 965 966 966 so I'm in a
good spot right now and then I'm just
gonna hit the ground running and boost
on us yeah good like hunter and Titan
and warlock or 6363 for bounties most of
those are weaklings done hunters the
last would just kind of see if I can get
enough squeezed in there over the
weekend I was working on like planetary
stuff and I just haven't even unlocked
the Mon so that just takes some of those
out but I was gonna be close I've never
done that kind of grind before and again
I'm not going for like flawless weekend
first time cuz I had family in town so I
don't even get to play so that's gonna
be a rough weekend cuz I'll just like
see Twitter exploding I'll be like I'll
just wait till everybody goes to sleep
and coming here in tightly trying like a
level up personally stress and bounding
so it's it's coming so spend your
weekend go buy your final exotic engrams
from Zerg go do your final prep if you
want to do it or just sleep put the game
down for a couple days and get a fresh
head coming into the new season which is
gonna keep us all quite busy it sounds
like ready I'm ready
Brian is back yeah oh yeah we have hit
all sorts of a long podcast so thank you
guys who have been sticking with us for
awhile before we go I don't let sir
thank you for joining us ba Buzard Bobby
your head like it has been a lot of fun
sir this is a lot of fun yeah either as
you know I love Destin I spend a lot of
hours in it so getting to talk and chat
about it and I have all these ideas that
I just send out on Twitter but being
able to bounce ideas off all that what I
like is hearing the reaction right away
so crazy ideas so yeah I appreciate it
guys thank you for having absolutely you
will see some more screaming yeah what's
that you want to see you doing streams
getting back yeah yeah I'll get it going
I think I might actually get it going
again you guys can watch my sniping I
was all about this sniping and
everyone's called me Bobbie Snipes so I
got to bring that back bring back Bobby
Snipes back might have to recruit some
help for that trial run cuz I am yeah
although they can get oh yeah well let
everybody know where they're at where
you can find you you want to throw some
poor you go to my Twitter all my links
are in there that's where I'm most
active I got Instagram I got it all I
don't really post much on YouTube
anymore and I don't stream much anymore
but I'm gonna try to do that and I got
some other thing things in the work as
well that are relating to what we're
doing right now so yeah follow me on
Twitter I have some some crazy ideas and
stuff so you can find me on there quick
rapid three hours here yeah I know I
know I did a melon one it was crazy
everything was gonna be a little you
know first was Luther barbers are coming
through man cool dude got a chance to
beat him at PAX like I said the passion
is there it's always good to talk to
fellow destiny brethren at the last word
so this is mad fun man definitely you
know means we kind of do more this and
oh yeah bet you already know you can
find me at Lourdes Carlino on Twitter
our Lord podcast returns from PAX East
Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern is the Lord's
Day no special guest just gonna do recap
what my brother's talking about the show
talked about all the topics latest
topics in gaming what's going on so it
should be a fun fun show appreciate the
support also Supreme you know I
appreciate the website support Lords
gaming dotnet really got a lot of
positive feedback from a lot of the
stuff we're doing and shout out to my
boy dizzy you know say he put up a
fantastic article about gaming with
cancer for what he's going through and
it's cool to see the community actually
come together and some
or us on that man I was really cool to
see but yeah man I sit and of course you
know you don't have to say sure you
listen man to note the last word my boy
he bought this man again passionate
discussion it's all comes from a good
place and it's always good every Friday
gentle in the mornings but afternoons
when we have big guests like Bobby and
we do it up you know say so salut to buy
bro and the last word and yeah for me
Yvonne says every Vegas fun with twitch
Twitter YouTube stream and probably a
lot of destiny if I can squeeze it in I
was trying to finish up neo but man that
game has got some length to it so catch
me on anywhere you can find me of course
on YouTube because we'll see plenty of
videos starting next Tuesday I'll try
and schedule some stuff over the weekend
I've got family and so I'm gonna be
crying while I'm not playing but it's
fine but yeah so would we wrap this
thing up it's always hard to time tours
of editing I get to do it later I was
wrap it up gonna give a little outro and
then I say it has been and what we try
and do say the last word all together
and that's how we in the podcast hints
the title so British everybody out there
in chat thank you guys very much for
being in here I'm gonna send you guys
over to follow up plays he stream and
he's full time now go see send him some
love so he's definitely a great nice guy
we met him at Guardian Colin I know you
guys I'm so episodes March 6 we got it
in got that nice afternoon Cognito got a
nap it was a good one thank you guys all
for hanging out and for this episode it
has been the last word